this show is presented by on it
the church what's happening now is
brought to you by
indochino that's indochino
our listeners get any premium indochino
suit for just 389
at indochino.com when you enter promo
code search at checkout that's a 50 off
the regular price for made to measure
premium suit and shipping is free
indoteno.com
church that's endo it's indochino.com
and to promo code church
shows also brought to you by lyft
whatever your reason is everyone needs
to make a little bit more money and the
best way to do it is driving for lyft
the ride sharing app that lets you be
your own boss pick your own hours and
earn up to fifteen hundred dollars a
week by by driving your own car
go to lyft.com joey today so you can
start making money and earn a 500
new driver bonus that's live.com joey
today
kick that mu lee it's monday
[ __ ] morning
here you go
it's turkey week [ __ ] get the gun
tell the pilgrim you're showing up with
a bigger dick than him
you're sitting at the head of the table
[ __ ]
churchill what's happening now
monday the 21st
we're here [ __ ] there you go
who's the boat
taking it back deep into the murky
waters of quaaludes this is cosby's
favorite song right here
this was his anthem as [ __ ] he'd show up
with a box of goodies
pudding and a big smile on his face
yeah let your shoulders bounce
[ __ ] you're at the light sitting
there like a moot
looking around let it hit you
bam
bam
[Music]
wiggly get this [ __ ]
take that mule lead kick it
you ain't [ __ ] around no more
it's november [ __ ] the devil is
dead
we killed that [ __ ] definitely
[Music]
oh [ __ ] what's happening you bad
[ __ ] it's a beautiful day to be
alive november 21st i got my main man
george perez in the house what's up man
lisa yeah in the [ __ ] house hello
i want to thank the people of houston
texas and they come and take a festival
you guys showed up in a [ __ ] tent in
the rain like savages out there and you
like that little trick i pulled with the
[ __ ]
smoke before the show i went when the
windiest place was i opened up the
curtain and i smoked a number in front
of there and the people i went with came
up to me afterwards
like people going oh my god he's close
by i can smell the reef i was shocking
because bro whenever you go on stage
it's like when you go to a concert
you're standing there waiting for the
band to go up even if it's a warm-up man
and all of a sudden you're uncertain
even though you're high and you had a
drink or two
but once you smell the marijuana
you know you're at the right place yeah
atlanta no no i've been there like i
like to smoke blunts a lot before mine
sure but
let everybody get the air it's like yeah
the whole room gets cleansed the spirits
the bad spirits go away this is the case
a bad comic leaves bad spirits in that
[ __ ]
i want to congratulate paula for passing
her bar it's very tough to pass on the
uh pass on the first time a mexican
woman making ways for herself you
understand me yeah and she studied all
summer she totally no sucky sucky
passed the bar exam and [ __ ]
that's the only bar i want it was worth
it apparently like only like 50 like 57
percent of people failed so over half
failed this time it's usually close to
50 50. what's the plan now now the plan
is uh her to look for she's been working
but it's been not pro bono but like
stuff like see so she can help her on
the office she wasn't really a lawyer um
but now she can start doing like go to a
law firm and
it's pretty crazy like she has to do
like community service first for like
those probation hours it wasn't really
community she was getting paid but it
was like uh
it's like a it's like a
a group that helps with uh mental health
issues it's not a state thing okay but
then the school it's something weird
it's something that the school doesn't
know
26 25 so 26 so now you're gonna work for
the prosecutor's office
you look up [ __ ] for a year okay you
look up different [ __ ] statutes and
[ __ ]
and then you move up one
and now you're in there talking with
them in the circle they let you let the
mexican girl come in here you know i'm
saying like you got to earn that chair
yeah toughen up being a woman that might
mean a woman of color in that [ __ ] in
that firm you have to have a certain
attitude those women to make it have to
have you ever watched law order whatever
it's a black attorney they don't [ __ ]
around hell they can't [ __ ] around and
they'll put lamigla on you right away
don't say a [ __ ] word about black
people i'll put [ __ ] aclu on you
[ __ ] so
it's really you know it's a great thing
to see you know like well it did so it's
five years around the court system
prosecuting getting to meet judges
clerks then they're the ones who run
[ __ ] yeah that's amazing remember the
clerk run [ __ ] okay oh yeah when you go
to court if you got a badass attorney
that [ __ ] will get you on the
docket you give him you give him that
retainer watch that [ __ ] go to
work well they said i can't go to court
for 72 hours no i'm gonna get you on the
docket this morning let me call my
assistant put them on the thing at 901 i
want them out of here by lunchtime yeah
you know i'm going to set it back look
if they're going to go for 25 000. i'm
going to talk to the clerk i play golf
with the judge i'll tell the judge that
you're a good kid you don't have nothing
else nothing you need to hide right they
always ask you right now yeah i've been
there you need to hide let me go in
there
the bail is this they how are you for a
[ __ ] anklet and there you are you
just don't learn that how to [ __ ] law
school that's a hustle
you know the best attorneys i ever dealt
with were the ones that did blow
were the ones that were kind of crazy
because they walked the side of the
fence
when you have a tight stick up your ass
like the guy that represented me for the
kidnapping he was brilliant how much was
the retainer on that that's a lot of
[ __ ] money
it was 10th
damn this is in the 70s this is 88 10.
29 anniversary
it was the 10th it was the 30th 29th
anniversary on friday i celebrated every
year i call him and leave him a message
he calls me back three days later
man yeah i i remember
i guess i got an ascendancy an attorney
this journey's now just for sentencing
where they're like hey we'll make sure
you get the less sentencing and i did he
got the
uh the great bodily injury enhancement
kicked off
and that's three years
i gave him 10 g's as well to hey you
know what
you can pay your way out of those years
i gave him 10 up front
five before i got sentenced
damn and 2500 when i got out to do all
the community corrections paperwork and
all that [ __ ] oh yeah
but this guy worked a miracle because
first off he he fought to get the
non-violent to get
he fought real hard to get the violent
thing off he goes if i can't get any
violence so he went through my police
record there was one thing when i was a
kid that i actually went to court for
like how old were you 18. i was 19
[ __ ] disappeared
disappeared
thank god for [ __ ] new jersey
where i grew up at the real spongebob
just disappeared
okay so that was number one then they
got a private investigator
to go back to jersey and investigate
everything
i had to pay that [ __ ] too like
10. yeah that's the real killer is the
investigator because the investigator
comes back with paperwork
and then he went and convinced him not
to hit me with a violent crime of
violence because when you do a crime of
violence if you get nine years you do
eight and a half yeah it's eighty-five
percent that's eighty-five percent
no
let's get that switch so he got me
second-degree burglary
accessory to a felony
and there was something else
probably something else what else that
got convicted of two of them no no
because i had two families
ago uh whatever it was second degree
burglary aggravated assault an accessory
to a felony oh yes
that's and that was the one that held me
up a little bit so as soon as i got
sentenced i got four years but two days
right in the system they tell you come
here
you're non-violent yeah
you're done you're the house bill 1200
house bill 1200 cuts that sentence right
in half so for 48 months becomes 24 and
you're eligible for a halfway house at
18. you don't get to go to the halfway
house until 16 months
so basically you did i did two more i
did a month in county which counts for
two yeah those are double credits so i
had 22 months to do
right off the bat
19 first day as soon as we went to as
soon as i got sentenced he found the
motion reconsideration 120 days so no
matter what
yeah i was okay i had vacuum even if the
reconsideration failed
he would so i went to work i started
writing the attorney letters
i started writing the judge letters
i'm at canyon city
i just did this i wrote that
[ __ ] judge a letter every week
i was in jail though
wow that turns their life around did
they ever write you back yes they do yes
and then he not only wrote me back but
when i went to court for reconsideration
he spoke to me and he spoke to me like a
human being and he said listen man those
letters meant the world
hand-written letters every friday night
he got him by tuesday yeah it was the
effort that you guys it was like every
three weeks he'd write me a letter and
say thank you very much
i see that you're trying really hard
you know i got so i could see i remember
the one letter he wrote that he could
see
i was trying real hard
but that i didn't address the main
situation which was coming to terms of
what i had done that's why you're
sitting in that [ __ ] barracks right
now and i accepted it what are you gonna
do you gotta write
in other words you gotta write a lot is
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] hey you know
what's crazy is what you just said i
didn't know until this last case i took
because the judge
was like
i'm gonna give you three years half time
i go to i go to prison and then you know
you got to see a counselor there your
counselor breaks you down and she was
like no you're doing 85
so i wrote the judge and i said hey man
check this out you told me this they're
telling me this
he wrote me back he goes hey man sorry
about what i said but you're you're with
them now
and that was it i did my time but he
wrote your back yeah he wrote me back
and it was like a classy ass letter you
ever write him back and tell him thank
you yes i did yeah yeah
yeah because they always write those
people back it's so weird how
and then when they released me
i took a couple months off i started
[ __ ] up in the halfway house and i
still wrote them letters once a month i
just didn't mention the damage i was
doing at the halfway house because for
the
probation violations they would never
bring me in front of him they brought me
to a different judge like this lower
class yeah i think so i didn't really
mention it i just talked about my job
and i was trying to get back into cu and
blah blah blah blah blah blah
and then something happened
something [ __ ] happened when i got
out of the system i wrote him a letter
when i got married i wrote him a letter
oh i know i kept writing this dude
letters dog [ __ ] yeah super pen pal but
at the halfway house like i heard those
are like
prison parties like my friends tell me
like
dawg you live in a bunk it's you and
your friend and there's like uh i say a
room like this would be a bunk of what
six people yeah is it seven
five
seven in a two bedroom apartment or
three
in a one-bedroom apartment in boulder on
canyon boulevard
this is you know i don't know if you
know if it's canyon i might be this
probably is wrong i'm thinking of laurel
canyon and it was an apartment building
i know laurel canyon okay no no this
isn't lowercase this is a boulder it was
an apartment building that the
it's a business and people really need
to understand that prisons are a
business yes halfway houses are a
business so there was a group of people
three or four people that were the
owners and they had lctc and bctc
and they also had boulder county
correctional treatments okay i got you
at longmont treatment center and what
you did was it was a halfway house so
they rented the apartment buildings
right they bought the buildings to the
property then they got the state
to fund them to fund them and pay for
the apartments but guess what
they charge you
not a lot they don't they make you 75
bucks a week yeah because you have to
get a job and like i guess you have to
get a shot not a lot out until you get a
job
you you're allowed out to get a job okay
yeah a lot out like if you don't have a
job you're allowed out from 9 to 12.
and you have three hours to list the
places you went to how you got there
show them the now you got to show them
now you're dead
if you're not if you're in the system
right now you're dead because if you're
in a halfway house i can't even imagine
how they program yeah they got your
social media well actually i do know how
they do how they program because i
remember i should do uh before all this
comedy [ __ ] i used to be a telemarketer
i was that guy that would call you and
try to sell you time-sharing [ __ ] like
hey i'm calling for pacific monarch you
won the mustang
and they had those people doing
telemarketing they were like oh
like we live in this halfway house like
the company they were in together they
were like just give us all these people
we need them to make calls and we'll
give them minimum wage and you guys can
take your cut
it's [ __ ] super business it's a
business this place it was 75 bucks a
week but you got
food
like your own food nothing healthy
frozen pizza tv dinners
bread it's really cheap ass salami and
ham
really bad cheese
what kind of what area of town was it in
i was just imagining it was in a pretty
decent part of boulder and where people
freak out what people like look at you
as you were coming in and out of it it
had a back entrance they had like a
glass window and you walked in there to
buzz you in and then there was a
bathroom right there because if you
opened up your folder to sign in
if there was a red dot on your folder
you had to p you had yeah three hours to
pee
what people don't understand is
there's some people who could do time
and get it over i could do the time and
get it over can i do 10 years now can i
do 15 years i don't think so
but
to get like a short time a short
sentence three four years two years you
could do that
a lot of people
cannot make
the adjustment to a halfway house
because they're complete it's harder
different type of rules like i remember
they were taking one person a day out of
there yeah and then they didn't do
anything bad
they were somewhere they weren't
supposed to be like a girlfriend's house
they were caught driving
you know little infractions they would
send you back
i've been very lucky i don't i haven't
had any issues i've heard probation is
us like a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] like it
depends what type of probation formal
informal
depends there's levels for what you do
if i say you listen if you're a [ __ ]
junkie and i go you listen you're going
to come in here once a month i'm going
to get a piece of your hair you're dead
you got two years
you're pretty much dead you're gonna
slip straight up with the hair
you're gonna slip listen you have to
leave and we've spoken about this years
ago
that you have to when you're on
probation and i did it guys i did it i
did
14 months on probation and knock on wood
because i was put on probation from
was it informal or formula you had to
check in right oh [ __ ] yeah yeah and i
had a call of color on monday wednesdays
and fridays
and if your color comes up you got three
hours to show up but they put a warrant
out for your arrest
you know uh
then i got out of the halfway house and
i was on probation
till
1991 yeah [ __ ] i can't my probation was
till 94 guys
oh
so what were the rules of your probation
my rules of my probation at this time
once i got out of the county corrections
community corrections there was three
different levels there was
the
uh prison system okay then there's
community corrections work release
okay and then there's probation
okay so i was put on probation
at that time
i didn't have to piss
i had to write a letter
pay a fee
23 a month or something
and it was pretty easy once i went on
probation i i didn't really get my
problem it was all over after that could
you smoke weed
they didn't piss me my attorney made it
clear that's it he made it clear no more
he's not in he paid his dues
that's it so i had no piss i was working
at the car wash i was stealing
i was feeding my family and one day i
bumped into this d.a i had known him for
months
and i asked him what he did he told me
i'm on probation he asked me for what i
don't
he goes when i go back to my office i'll
take a look at it
and about a week later he goes listen
have your attorney file a motion i'll
get you on probation yeah dude parole is
worse
worse that's when they come to your
house yeah yeah they get unannounced yes
and like it's like their mission to be
like hey i'm gonna try to get you they
tell you i'm gonna try to get you dog
look up look at the ufc now
right whether you saw if you're in the
ufc with usada you have to zone in and
tell them where you're going to be at
all times what do you mean usada shows
up in your house dog
is that is that the people that test for
like the blood can you imagine you had a
[ __ ] at the comedy store about to go on
stage
and these [ __ ] show up for a
blood test i'm dabbing up i'm done i
gotta quit i can't handle that [ __ ]
there's tapes of everybody i'm the guy
going into the shower with tim kennedy
kennedy came home sweaty i want a piss
test can i go in the shower you can't
leave my eyesight yeah they walked in
the shower with him while tim kelly was
in there washing with the curtain open
and then there was the [ __ ] another
incident somebody else oh nick diaz they
went to that [ __ ] crazy man's
house at six they told him go [ __ ]
himself he's going to sleep
it's crazy yeah i can't live on that
normal unless you've done that type of
living
and at first i i adjusted to the to the
community corrections those
[ __ ] would come to my house
once a month
like like would would they knock or like
did they have the power to raid your
house no they come and knock come in
look around talk to my wife
talk to me a little bit go in my office
sit with me
let's go upstairs to your bedroom
where's your office let me look at you
they had the power to open up your desk
or something i don't know what it was
they didn't have the power to open
anything up but if they smelled or saw
anything suspicious yes exactly
and i remember one time me
and two of my buddies like i went to i
got my attorney i gave my turn like a
grand
and i could go in there and tell him i'm
going to [ __ ]
san francisco for five days
and this [ __ ] went in there and
told him and i got five days off yeah
you gotta fight five day pass they asked
me for everything plane tickets hotels
the plan was this is how [ __ ] cokey
and fiendy i was
i bought two tickets for san francisco
i got hotel rooms for three of us
and i had a friend of mine in san
francisco
go to that hotel
and take the calls in my hotel room
he was going to check in with me
bro was a horrible scam
but for me to do what i wanted to do
with my buddies we wanted to go to aspen
and rent the hotel room and snort coke
my buddies flew out from jersey
i pick them up at the airport monday at
lunch time wait wait so were you already
in at you're already in aspen but
already i'm living in boulder so you
told them someone says got it i tell the
probation officers
that if my friends are flying in i'm
gonna bring them back to boulder we're
gonna get some to eat
and then we're gonna drive back to
stapleton airport at the time this is
way before
uh the airport that stand now and we're
gonna fly to san francisco around 8
o'clock
how long is that flight to san francisco
yeah in those days three hours we got
that 11 or something okay i don't know
what time exactly hey that was the plan
well let me tell you something guys
we they come over i pick them up and
their package is
ginormous
they go like rock talking two ounces of
coke for three days damn you guys
brought snow to the snow dog this
[ __ ] came in and we because it
was two of my buddies one was very
conservative
but he snorted like all of us but the
other guy was just a wild man he wasn't
in my house two minutes
he was showing it to me was a two pieces
he broke yeah
we grinded up we started snorting do you
know we're in there about an hour and a
half talking and there's a door knock
it's my [ __ ] probation officer
and it's you and three dudes in the room
two dudes we're upstairs
and he's knocking knocking knock and
knocking
and then about 20 minutes he leaves and
my phone rings oh we're [ __ ] paranoid
we're so i'm busting he catches me going
to piss me
he kept calling me calling me calling
the house then he left and i saw that he
went up the corner and parked
that he took off and me and my buddies
got that [ __ ] rented car and took the
[ __ ]
off and he asked me what happened and i
told him that my friends got delayed oh
good yeah why would you show up like
that that was it i got away with it he
knew
yeah when i got back on sunday because i
got back
on sunday
to him
i was getting back sunday or something
but i really got back on friday and
those guys were leaving friday so that
would give me a couple days to clean off
and i would have to go see him on monday
something it was something crazy the
coke
we were doing coke that i would have 72
hours to clean out yeah and that would
be sweating flushing i would drink
[ __ ] may lockers
vinegar a dog i drank a bottle of
vinegar one time and still came up hot
yeah
light distilled vinegar with gatorade
dog not even mixed i would take a sip of
the vinegar and then drink the [ __ ]
gatorade you have no idea what i did for
that [ __ ] you had no idea on a monday
morning i would wake up and i'd call and
it'd be my color
oh
and i would have to run
and go do you want another water i'm
guessing i would have to run and go to
the [ __ ] safeway
and get [ __ ] a bottle of white
distilled vinegar the big one
32 ounces whatever that big one is not
the little one guys yeah i know what
you're talking about i would open it up
in my counter and i would stand over the
[ __ ] what's the sink yeah
and i would drink a [ __ ] blast of
vinegar and just
didn't throw up ever
sometimes then i drank the [ __ ] just
thinking about it oh my god yeah [ __ ]
and there's there's nothing in your pace
to tell them that you just drank a
bottle of vinegar it doesn't matter
then i never passed it with that [ __ ] i
didn't start
i had to break the machine i would put
like pool cleaner
i would put pool cleaner in my
turtleneck because i'm uncircumcised
wait if you know that no exactly yeah
you got to put bleach or something right
there are you addicted well if you knew
you were going to do that why did you
keep drinking the vinegar
because if that necessarily said that if
you drank vinegar and cranberry juice
yeah you would beat coke i drank vinegar
a thing of gatorade
a gallon of cranberry juice a gallon of
water i mean when i walked in there my
piss was negative water like it was just
it was clear still clear my system and i
still came back positive
[ __ ]
it must have been like that was one of
the lee
just walking around
knowing you're gonna get a piss test
it's a horrible horrible heart and not
like mailman
mailman might get tested and they can go
eight years without getting tested
i'm talking about
when you know you're gonna get tested
once a week and whatever you do on
friday is not going to be out of your
system by monday morning and the more
you get high on friday
they're going to catch you on a monday
and it's always on a monday because they
know the weekend is where the real
weekends at the real parties at
so
why even
like is that why people run like i'm
surprised if you know you're going to
get a contest and go back to jail why do
you even go in and do the piss test
because you take a chance some some i
don't know how your probation but i
remember my pro officer would be like
look dog you're gonna get [ __ ] high
tell me
i don't need to do the paperwork or
you're going back in you're working a
little bit they they kind of
were lenient with you if you were
showing progress they're like all right
look we're gonna put you in a class i'm
not gonna lock you up they weren't
showing me no leniency because i was
involved in a drug case oh so they went
after my drug use they i had to have to
they knew so they show you a show a
bleach dick oh my god you have no idea
the things i did as a fiend in those
days
my heel it took my dick to heal like 10
11 years oh my god i had blotches on my
helmet
i wouldn't even ask people to suck my
dick on the scared that they thought i
was like a leper i had pieces of skin
missing off my helmet it was disgusting
for years right was it like albino no
because i put drano on my dick you're
just burning away and i busted that
[ __ ] machine that time and they knew
i busted that machine like three times
one time i put drano and the thing was
flowing it was what
traino is the worst drug
it was a terrible two years for me guys
was it by your piss hole you like so did
you put draenor like i know you're
talking about i'm not circumcised either
i'm not even i put a piece of drano to
cover my dick like a like like jesus
they put him in a cave with that rock in
front of it
and then when he pushed it that was the
drano that was the drano i would put
that that's how i would hide it because
they were starting to look at my dick
yeah like i would have to take my dick
and show it to the probation officer and
go see i got nothing oh because there
was a dude named noah moulet
stormin norman ouellette was a bad
[ __ ] this guy was doing pounds
of blow and his [ __ ] halfway house
room
but he devised a thing where he got a
hot water bottle the old school where
your mom used to wash a monkey once a
month when he got a period
it was a hot water bottle with a hose he
made a skinny hose and he'd scotch tape
it to his dick all the way down the
bottom oh and when he had a piss he had
a device and he'd sit there and go i
can't pee and that'd be the be pumping
his arm and the piss would come out and
he'd be clean all the time storm and
norman would figure out a way how to go
in there with his jaw going
and let me tell you something else about
storm and norman
stormy norman was one of the best car
salesmen i ever saw in my life dog
storm and norman could go into a store
and cause havoc on the reels like on a
real basis he worked with me for two
months and i learned more from storm and
norman and he wasn't a thief car
salesman he was not a very good car
salesman he just knew how to put you in
a bind what was his approach like put
you in a bind or was he tell you that
your car's a piece of [ __ ] tell you how
bad it was gonna last tell you what the
value was on it why it wasn't gonna work
out for you you're a nice person you're
a family you got three kids you can't
count on that [ __ ] car and i don't
want you to drive that car no more come
on come on inside i'm going to take care
let me show you this car and meanwhile
every car he made a thousand dollar
problem he was a great [ __ ] salesman
but he couldn't stay clean storming
norman stormy norman was worse than i
was at that time
storming norman made me look like a
[ __ ] quiet boy
yeah i i have some pretty crazy coke
stories too man like the coke buddies
but like uh
being off when you were in jail were
they doing blow
you know what i don't think so i mean i
know they were but i that was one drug i
didn't see because it's imagine being
there
[ __ ] paranoid and you really can't do
shell you can't leave your cell like it
would suck when i was locked up at every
level there was drugs
that's what really shocked me not and i
never ever ever
because it was a scam and a half they
called them matchbooks or something so a
matchbook a weed which is
basically who joins [ __ ] that was 50
bucks and your wife had to put money on
the guy's books before you got it coke
for a little little taste the kid showed
me once it was two tenths
it was a hundred dollars they charged
it was good coke i didn't do it with him
i could just tell it was a nice little
rock wasn't re-rocked it was shiny
for what you what you paid 25 dollars
for what would it would have three
tenths three yeah
bucks and he was telling me because it
last me two weeks how yeah and he goes i
do a little bump here and there like fly
at night i jerk off
i watch tv and i [ __ ] roll over and
go to bed what are you thinking the
heroine was rampant oh that heroine was
a
you know and then the white dudes like
the supremacists and the guys that kkk
and the bikers they were heavy into the
speed oh yeah they were heavy into the
speed and they got it brought during
visitation time through the mouth
i read this article about this dude who
did acid in prison that seems like i
would not sit in prison oh my god how
was that tremendous
i don't know
you recommend it or what it was uh
i became friends with the librarian
oh yeah there's always a [ __ ] free
staff the librarian had glasses he was
in there for murder and his wife and the
mailman
this is still the truth he had two
thousand years he had two thousand years
he wasn't going nowhere but they trusted
him so they put him in a camp yeah and
he was a librarian he had like 10 years
left to be honest with you and i was wow
he had already done 15. if i was 27
he was 45 better look 27. no he was a
hippie he rolled his own cigarettes
and he was very intellectual oh yeah and
i would go in there to read the paper
after i'd washed dishes in that stock
room i'd go in there and reap the paper
and he would talk to me from time to
time then a couple people going to read
the paper we'd have conversations
and me and him stuck together he was
from buffalo
and one day he told me he could get it
because i do it all the time man
because they can't test you for that
yeah well i don't know what yeah i don't
think they had to test your spine or
something but not to throw you off see
i also figured out the rotation for my
p-test
what's called a rainbow
test
is very expensive
and the state gets sick and tired of
paying for those
okay this i bet by now you're paying for
your own piss test and that's killing
[ __ ] no they're not doing like
the what they're doing now is they're
not even having you on parole anymore
really you have like a probation officer
now it's like over-assigned but through
the pistol bottles they take your hand
out here no uh you have to piss you
don't even have to piss in front of them
no more really but you gotta piss in
that room a special room they got and
you just take a piss and then they'll
let you know by the end of the day if
they're gonna come get you
the secret of probation
is not to go out at night
yeah the temptation that's it that's it
once you come to that conclusion
that you could take your dog for a walk
meet your friend and smoke a joint in
your neighborhood and go home
and be in bed by nine and lift weights
and read a book or watch tv or because
you have to get so into your job that's
how i did it i got so into my job
and so into what i was doing if i bought
coke i bought it in the daytime
you following scientist i know exactly
myself a reason
to go out at night
if you go to a bar
20 times eventually something's going to
happen one night when the cops come
there you are they take your name in the
report
months later your probation officer
calls you and says why were you at that
bar
that's it might take 30 days it might
take 60 days but eventually all these
little things add up you know what i'm
saying you go to a party where there's
[ __ ] known people there's a fist
fight
there's so many easy ways to trip up
you go home get into an argument with
your wife the cops call the neighbor the
neighbors call the cops
you're going to jail there's
it's such a fine [ __ ] line today yeah
if you have any police contact you have
to report it within 24 hours to your
parole officer hey
i seen this cop i got pulled over this
is his name and then
boom
for me not leaving the house like you
it would be annoying to not be able to
leave the house at night but it wouldn't
be a big deal who the [ __ ] is it
right who the [ __ ] are you kidding you
[ __ ] get food shipped
would shower at night maybe
you would sit there come out looked
around the sun and go not for me today
yeah or if you could edit from the house
and not leave your house late oh yeah i
would worry about you you wouldn't never
see the sun
he would get food delivered all through
me
you think i'm kidding
is he one of those guys to get this
[ __ ] food delivered and
he won't leave that [ __ ] house if you
let him when i first met him
he got grubhub the other [ __ ]
some dude delivering your food yeah
get em
they you to today like some [ __ ] bum
delivers my food you don't deliver
either not anything i let those italians
deliver
they deliver it right to my [ __ ] door
and it's the same guy every time i was
so joey what's up buddy how are you
great to see you you got the insanity
[ __ ] yeah i got the insult look at the
[ __ ] size of it
man you know what i had speaking of food
you know you remember sopas [ __ ] yeah oh
my god where'd you ever man hawaiian
gardens
old ladies like paisas like like like
mantel only and
they don't there's more white people
there than mexicans eating the food it's
oh yeah she keeps the [ __ ] lights on
he keeps the lights on pedro and his
eight kids they're coming for [ __ ]
tostadas and everybody goes home yeah
it's the white people that like eating
guts and please and [ __ ]
oh my god juanita she's been our
waitress for years now
you know what kind of like trips me out
is like the mexicans will treat their
whites better than you because they're
like hey dog you're going to keep coming
here if if these fools give us a bad
review we're gonna get shut down and
notice like when i go to cl like like
there's that one taco love right by the
the life factory
they rush the street yeah they treat me
like [ __ ] there and it's a trip are they
any good that restaurant sucks i just
wanted to try it i heard it sucks yeah
how about the other one you go the other
one on sunset across from uh
that one used to be very good i think i
know you're talking about and they have
the fancy ass plates that are real heavy
this is no no this is across from where
belushi killed himself oh and richard
pryor on sunset boulevard right there
when you make the turn on sunset there's
a billboard and it's right before
is it by peeing down no it's on the
other side oh come on we want you guys
all right you're coming from laurel
canyon you make a right to go to the
comedy store there's that mall right
there with a kung fu school and the
mcdonald's on the corner yeah okay you
keep going
20 yards there's a liquor store on the
right you keep going now there's a bank
on the left
you keep going and there's a little
mexican hut right there i've never been
there okay they're great yeah but it's
30
oh my god they got these [ __ ] potato
and like a thing
with the sauce on it jesus [ __ ]
christ for 30 [ __ ] dollars i don't
know but it's like it's two people okay
it's me you if we get you know
an appetizer the small and the special
like uh three tacos rice and beans
and a soda you know that's why you get
that in the hood for ten dollars
where i live it's like the tacos are a
dollar and they're you can get eight
tacos and they give you the avocado they
like the lemon they grow them in their
backyard
eight bucks dollar for horchata that's
nine bucks for like two people i i love
where i live i live like on the border
of orange county l.a
so uh the food is
ridiculous i'm lucky
i mean everybody has good food
everywhere but
i can't give it up to the hollywood
boulevard or sunset food it's too
expensive and they don't treat you right
joe's on hollywood boulevard is good the
pizza joint there's a little i've been
there there's a little
spanish [ __ ] honduran
el salvador family that owns a juice
stand
they've been there and they've been in
hollywood bro since i moved here i've
been eating there for 20 years i've gone
there when i was all coked out the next
morning they make pink clouds
milk with uh whatever a little bit of
honey they make the natural fruit and
then they make four types of sandwiches
they make a tuna on whole wheat
they make a [ __ ] turkey right lee i'm
taking you there whatever i've done
there i've gone there my salad oh it's
delicious
have you ever had salt pesley oh yeah
i've had i've had all that because of
paula and oh i've talked to people and i
know there's some great fancy mexican
food
and i haven't i haven't tried like i
haven't tried fancy but my problem with
the other like
not even el torito because that's even
too that's hard that's even too wide oh
but that's horrible any sort of any sort
of mexican restaurant that's like tries
to be too fancy i don't i don't i don't
like it it's just it doesn't seem i'm an
acapulco type of [ __ ] yeah i
could play one in silver lake i'll go
there eight times i haven't been there i
gotta say five [ __ ] years but the
lunch special that acapulco like on
tuesdays it's basic cheese enchiladas
some rice they got a great [ __ ] soup
there they got desserts i don't touch
the desserts
i like mexican food but i'll tell you
what
i do not like
when they turn
a simple menu into an expensive menu
yeah
that's what gets under my crawl
sometimes if you want to charge me that
you better justify it it better be that
good like you said that dollar tacos
yeah
either [ __ ] dollar black beans and
rice whatever bro yeah cooked bean what
they call them free fried yeah and rice
three dollars for the whole [ __ ] dish
and it's a dish like a killer mule
you know
they give you extra 20 years you know
but then you go on someplace and they
want to charge you 18.95
for that [ __ ] plate with three little
pieces of meat whatever
that's you know hey listen it's uh
everybody has their own taste that's uh
yeah that's the beauty of ours george
perez you've been on the [ __ ] podcast
tale lately i ain't [ __ ] around dog
and uh adam carolla yeah that was crazy
that was [ __ ] crazy he just called
you out of the blue uh
yeah well this guy named i'm doing the
mangria tour adam carolla has a ipa beer
and he has mangria
and they're doing a tour with their band
and they're like me and redman
so they called us up there and last time
we did the tour red band got to go on
corolla
but this time you know hey man dr drew
was there what do you say
he didn't say [ __ ] to me man but i could
tell he wanted like to hug me or
something you can't stop snorting and
she can't stop i can listen i can't stop
snorting i got a friend
i just i don't know it was a it was a
trip how to play with his head doctor
drew dr driving done drugs in two weeks
but i'm dying to snort a [ __ ] kilo
right now
i'm about to call some of the sons of
anarchy to drop off
and a backpack
you're really making it work for
yourself my friend hey man i i'm taking
your advice i'm grinding
and i'm
gonna take it to the next level as far
as but um
dude i see hey joey
man i remember you're the first one of
our journey you're like but you know
what i'm talking about you're the first
one to go into podcasting that i
followed for and
you and lee are killing the dog
we're trying yeah now you killing that
dog that's why we have you on it we love
it i love it yeah i was at a birthday
party today and i was like [ __ ] yeah i'm
coming it's uh it's amazing what the
platform for podcast has become i know a
lot of people now when i go to shows
i talk to a lot of people after the
shows they all talk to me about the
different podcasts they listen to
and it's really interesting that this is
it this is the next medium
i don't know how long it'll last me and
leah in this thing for the [ __ ]
wheels fall off because i don't give a
[ __ ] about the money you know what i'm
saying we'll make it work
one way or another this is just
really getting what you believe
in out letting people know who the [ __ ]
you are from straight up
that's the most important thing
people calling me up all the time they
go dog i'm trying to put together a
podcast it's really funny you know what
there's a lot of funny out there
maybe people want you to tell them a
funny with a story or how you got there
blah blah blah blah blah blah whatever
this has become more intimate now
entertainment has become more intimate
now yeah they want to know like what
you're doing or what you're upbringing
as far as right anything if you listen
man the most important
i was always raised to believe and if i
believed it for a while
everybody believed it
everybody is raised to believe that
these so-called celebrities are better
than you
that somehow you're so right on the
money
that's better than you that somehow they
were raised better than you or something
like that
and
i don't know i always felt that that was
such a [ __ ] story when people call
me a celebrity because i've been in
movies i got pissed off
i'm a dirty comedian bro
i got to a movie because i saw a
breakdown i said you know i needed coke
money
if you noticed since i stopped snorting
coke i don't really want to be in the
movies no more
when i was doing coke i want to be in
the movies because i wanted that [ __ ]
scale money you know i want 10 days on
your movie set
at [ __ ] scale plus 20 hours of
overtime yeah
now i don't want to do dick
i want to do stand up and i want to come
through the podcast with my little
jewish friend over there
what's the next jewish holiday brother
probably hanukkah a couple weeks right i
don't know it starts christmas eve this
year it's late it's late yeah yeah yeah
i was just thinking about it i don't
know
you're gonna bust out the black suit
and the [ __ ] codfish liver i didn't
know what you were gonna do
hanukkah is pretty cool it's eight
nights i'm looking forward so talk to me
about your weekend at pismo beach oh
dude it's great
how was the hotel room hotel room was a
little janky i'm gonna be very honest a
little a little janky they didn't mean
they didn't
it was nice but like
not really like they didn't really take
care of it it was weird uh my girlfriend
was laughing the housekeepers were white
and they were loud as [ __ ] in the
morning
like walking up and down the halls the
the free breakfast
was terrible like the eggs the scrambled
eggs tasted like they were like they
made hard-boiled eggs and then just
chopped them up
and then and then like the waffle mixed
with sour so we said [ __ ] that uh but
though the bed was nice it was a great
area but there was no traffic there it
was amazing it was the beach where the
beach was right there we saw a seal
just out there was [ __ ] cool uh we
went the butterfly thing was that was
kind of cool it kind of freaked me out
because there were like i think they
said
25 000 butterflies and they kind of like
cling onto each other and make like
little bug
grenades and freaking that i don't like
that
um
but yeah then we last night we went and
got a two steak we got two rib eyes
and uh yeah it was just that's
i i just saw it when i was a dessert
last night [ __ ] yeah we got dessert
though
oh [ __ ] what was it
it was like a toasted marshmallow thing
like they toasted a marshmallow over
like this ice cream thing it was like
ice cream on like a little piece of cake
oh my gosh this guy's a [ __ ] savage
that's a super meal right he's a bad
[ __ ] he don't stop he don't stop
this book no you can't stop he likes
that they threw him off the [ __ ]
zipline and we talked about that he
showed up the zip line
they said well look at that savage and
they're like listen and they're gonna
work out for you right
first of all
they said don't start please don't even
but i got the whole story from a
confidential source
you have to put the brakes on you almost
took down 10 people
no wonder they went out of business they
got 10 insurance claims
they threw them up they wrote them up i
don't know
they're scam artists like hans are blind
and i will zip line again no you will
notice i will zip one nobody ever
[ __ ] let you
he's on the 86 list yeah no i'm wrong
that's the 86 list he's on the 86 list i
could have paid another 200 bucks to try
again but he couldn't pay 200
insurance
that's why it was 150 for you to go down
that [ __ ] rope
because you know what the chance of you
breaking at the same chances of me
breaking it high dude they don't they're
used to skinny people 160 170. that's
who's crazy enough to zipline you and me
show up two little [ __ ] gorillas
that rope is going down though and
they're scared you scare people
if i'm on the line and i see you or you
see me
you don't need that in your life it's
worth in cliffhanger
you might as well drop your [ __ ] wife
it's over this [ __ ] galook is getting
on there think about reality lee
you're a skinny guy you weigh 150 pounds
mistake in your pocket and also i'm
ziplining with my little [ __ ] helmet
on and i'm trying to get momentum and i
look up on top and you're the next
you're coming down behind me what do you
think that does to you well they're not
still on the line they don't what line
what line you're not even gonna get
you're gonna go down like a [ __ ]
listen if i across the street there's 50
[ __ ] floors if i take a rock and
throw it off the top by the time that
gets to the bottom it's a missile george
yeah that'll go right through your head
and come out through your [ __ ] yeah
that's like you
i see you i'm on the bottom trying to
get momentum i see you getting on that
[ __ ] rope are you kidding me i'll
just jump off i'll just take my helmet
and let go i don't need this first of
all i won't let you know i'm very
graceful on the zip line what graceful i
i i camp that's how that's that's how i
roll listen
i got to do the superman thing yeah i
could use no you can't stop you couldn't
i couldn't they gave me one shot that
the what are you those that's all you
need no what happens if you're coming
down on top of three kids they usually
have them with 82 miles an hour
they don't leave them hanging there
elected like pinballs to get hit yes
they do because you got you got to be
fast than anybody else i went through
the training they take training
i don't know the high school kid took us
through this thing he you stand on a
little platform
is it virtual reality training no it's
not virtual reality a lot i'm a hard and
trained zipliner but i just didn't pass
i just didn't you're 86. i'm not 86.86
he's got to go to [ __ ] alvarado park
down there joe you might get some mail
saying you're going zipline you just
give it to you i don't go ziplining that
i wouldn't do that [ __ ] either and i'm
skinny unbelievable the [ __ ] i gotta
live with these are the calls i get
every week i get a new call
i would have got this call this week i'm
gonna look at butterflies i just hang up
i can't take that in my life 28 years
old gonna look at butterflies you say i
gotta live with i sat through a
butterfly lecture i know you did i know
you yeah that's right
were they playing that song goodbye
horses no there was no songs it was real
creepy it look it was just there's too
many bugs was there like a following
there too is there other people looking
at you yeah it's a state park they go to
that same place every year i've been to
one of those up there i ain't never been
i also went to the one down here in uh
downtown with the butterfly you gotta
take the baby okay you gotta go in there
you walk around like a mortadelle you
look at [ __ ] butterflies but this was
just out in the open this is just out in
the open because they're out in the open
flapping around no yeah well then yeah
there was no nets like when i grew up
they used to have like a butterfly zone
i never went in because i don't like
[ __ ] bugs but
it was like inside a building this is
just out in the open they just go to
that same place every year it's [ __ ]
they're [ __ ] smart like but what do
you mean in that like a butterfly net
like spongebob there's no nets there's
nothing
there's like there's no enclosure to
keep them in oh they just take off when
they want yeah they're well they're just
they uh they hibernate during the winter
they come here
these are the western monarchs this is
like a ghetto uh nature life channel
listening
he's like they just come dog yeah they
just they come from nevada they come
from arizona they come from uh oregon
and uh so it's kind of like the salmon
did you go to the movies last night no
we didn't go i'll go we just we just
wanted to eat dinner we wanted to eat
the steak it was
[ __ ] uh nothing really that big was a
new harry potter movie so we'll see it
some other time it's a prequel correct
uh kinda it's it's a way for her to make
another two billion dollars before she
before she retires it's it's it's not
it's just really it's new york like i
think it said like 70 years before harry
potter or something
just re recycling all this movie [ __ ]
with the stigma
not to me
i was never a stigma to a george because
i grew up around people that had gone
away
and it was
treated like somebody [ __ ] up and was
doing time
you know i grew up around a couple that
he would get locked up every two years
for four [ __ ] years and she would get
another lover
i know and then when he get out of jail
they disappear and he'd go back with her
husband
until finally he killed him and nato
marcelo his name was marcel and a black
dude a cuban dude in ireland i was a kid
when all this [ __ ] went down so i
understood it so when somebody said to
me oh my uncle my pr my cousin just come
out of prison
it didn't really affect me but i'm not
like most people
you know with all the stigma that goes
with that
like when you tell like if somebody went
up to lee and say i want to be big
business partners with you and an hour
later somebody called and said hey
that guy just got out of prison for
kidnapping watch yourself
lee wouldn't take my calls no more not
because i'm a bad person but just with
the statement that goes with being
in prison oh yeah
with the stigma that goes with it
where you and me are
in our lives especially in comedy i mean
oh it affects me all the time i mean
people look at us like this isn't a
tattoo shop that i don't have tattoos
from a tattoo shop you know what i mean
it's that
you ever watched those movies when they
got like the cambodian gangsters
they got the boats and [ __ ]
yeah that's how i feel when i look at
those people i feel like people look at
me like i'm like i know this is spread
to cambodians but they're just like
i know when i first got out going to
sell cars how people handled me
with like tender gloves for the first 60
days until i quit
i didn't like the treatment i wasn't
selling cars i was in shock still when i
got out on bail
when i got on bail i was still mentally
shocked and what happened
and i couldn't sell a car i couldn't
move forward so i went and i worked at a
rental car agency
but i remember that i went right from
county jail on friday
to work at this new place on monday the
general manager was my friend he really
liked eating care he was locked up at
some time
but i remember how they treated me
like they would whisper around me nobody
really
offered me donuts you know what i'm
saying
when they'll offer you donuts you got a
[ __ ] problem yeah but then when i
went to hertz those people were cool as
[ __ ]
you know they didn't give a [ __ ] the
chick ended up testifying for me i had
my friend oh wow
and still talk to us she was a character
witness the dude rich he was telling me
don't do the time dog
my brother owns the [ __ ] hurts in
nicaragua you go down there live like a
king and [ __ ] nobody'll find you down
there
and then the other dude brendan carello
was the guy who got me the job he
testified and wrote letters to the
judgment that was one of the best jobs i
ever had i heard
and i was doing some crazy [ __ ] dead
druids freaking with some freaks i'd
meet on the street there because they
had a garage but they had a back garage
hey is hertz the same [ __ ] that oj yes
they were huge
they were like the powerhouse of rental
cars they're still huge i don't know if
they're as huge as
what they well everyone's ubering now so
they're not doing the rentals or i don't
know well i know the uber business is
cutting to everybody's lunch
but there's people that want to drive
themselves and when you get off a
[ __ ] plane
you know
i don't know i don't know how i feel
about that listen i would right now at
this point in my life i would if i knew
somebody in each town that was very cool
and i could trust one person i would use
them and i would do more
but the uber in and all this stuff you
know lee and i went to boston a few
weeks ago
we had to take an hour and a half drive
the one night
on the way home that [ __ ] was
doing 100. no way he got oh that
[ __ ] got his home though by
midnight jack you gotta you gotta tip
him next to 20. he risked his ticket
[ __ ] for us
the guy there was the speed limit the
guy back he did [ __ ] 100
wow i i took my first uber by myself
ever last night just to another bar
and it was like weird
like i felt like
man if we get pulled over i don't know i
was like this guy doesn't know what to
do like i couldn't smoke in the car i
couldn't do what i wanted to do
it was i didn't it wasn't a good
experience for me and this was just five
minutes
yesterday was my friend's birthday he
turned 39 no 40 and we've known each
other since elementary
we got [ __ ] up everybody went back to
our our own original town orange
and we got [ __ ] up yesterday i rubed a
couple times and i lifted a couple times
both of them had been remarkable i was
in shock how fast it was and the price
um
i like it i don't know about the airport
one you got to wait on the line
and all that [ __ ] they can't drop you
off i don't like drama
yeah especially at the [ __ ] airport
don't drama me up
where's the taxi scan and don't make me
two miles away it better be out here
right now it's not bad it's it's it's
drama for the drivers but for for you
it's not bad they'll drop you off and to
pick up you just have to go upstairs to
uh
departures
it was weird to me because like like how
you said that stigma like they were
giving me the look like hey you know we
don't got no money you can't rob us
right like it was just weird it was
it was like a a 60 year old man and it
was just [ __ ] weird
for me and i was drunk i was [ __ ] up
so maybe that was it too think about
this right now if you had a family
and you had a full-time job
and on saturdays and sundays you could
just get your car keep it clean put some
waters back there a couple candies some
business cards
and just give people ubers all [ __ ]
day
and make 300 a day each day
that's 2400 extra a month for you that's
real in your [ __ ] car think about
that right now the same thing with lyft
you know
lyft sponsors the podcast you know why i
think it's a great opportunity
it really is if you're a young man right
now
you're not working how many times i've
asked are you drivers and lyft drivers
why do you have this there's either
students
a guy with a family
or people that can't find a [ __ ] job
there's really if you have a car now
there's really no reason to be
unemployed and the great thing about all
these companies are there are that even
let's say you don't have a car like
they're financing they're helping you
get cars
like or you can just lease a car from
like a rental place it's pretty cool so
it's uh
no i mean it's cool it was just
weird for me it was just because uh by
myself just by would you feel better in
a cab
no [ __ ] no i never do that i'd rather
drive in like wrist this is something
stupid i i'm not fooled i i when i'm
drunk i [ __ ] drive
i i i can't do that george but i don't
yeah all right
never never never never
you know as crazy as i used to get and
[ __ ] george
you want me to tell you something george
i can look at a judge and lie
i can look at a cop and tell you a story
and a half
if i had one cocktail with me
and i'm driving home and i'd see a
police car
my system would go crazy oh now i can
have an eight ball in the car be
completely straight to see a cop
and act like al capone i'll even take my
seat belt off in front of just to give
him a reason to pull me you know what
i'm saying yeah when you pull up to a
cop and you're holding
you got to be loose jack oh look at them
out the window
look around
they know they know how to judge a
person with a [ __ ] body in the trunk
they know the whole i look right at him
i look right at him
i cut in front of him a little bit
especially now i got nothing to hide now
now i [ __ ] with him today i did it i was
going to the weed store tonight some
dude was there at the light by uh
uh whatever the [ __ ] that is in studio
city and that's the light i stopped and
i even looked at him and right while he
was looking at me i moved up a little
bit i had my seat belts on i ain't
nothing in this [ __ ] car i got no
warrants i got no wants i got nothing
you could pull me over and break my
balls for what are you just bored during
the day or something why would you do
that to yourself because i i don't
listen
i don't break the speed limit oh my god
but you know wiley because for years i
would have something in the car and i
had to act like a half a fan like i was
having a nervous breakdown now do you i
remember being in the car with my friend
jody and getting pulled over in houston
and she said to me give me the coke i'll
stick it in my [ __ ] straight up that
[ __ ] cup that coke was all pussied up
when i took that aluminum i had an
aluminum foil i had a bundle i had a
baggie she stuck it on a little snatch
who gives a [ __ ] you know i because
there was a lot of times i had done a
wine at nine o'clock and now it's three
in the morning and i'm [ __ ] driving i
used to cop in silver lake and i used to
live in hollywood
i remember and i remember one night
driving back from silverlight dog
on sunset i thought i was gonna die
that's the worst i wasn't one of those
people that could snort and [ __ ]
drive and drinking and driving here's
the problem with drinking and driving
joyce that i don't like
there's 60 different angles and you know
that they all attack you all at once but
the most important one
you lose your license i can't do nothing
with you
i can't count on you no that's real talk
i can't count on you and at this
position in your life and who you are
you can't lose your license no i don't
do it no more i don't know
like i said
one night i did it maybe 25 years ago i
got home and that was it i said that
that'll never happen again
that's it that game will never happen
ever again you parked in the neighbor's
garage no i lost my mind i couldn't
handle the pressure
that's the one time i could not believe
that i could not handle pressure
if i'm in a car and i have two drinks
and there's a cop at the light going in
the opposite direction of me not even
thinking about me
my leg will go crazy i start getting
dizzy my legs really
come back if the cop pulls over
he'll know that there's something wrong
with me by the hyperventilation
now
do you know how many nights
i was at the same light i'm talking
about han
what's the street if you're drunk you
drive on kennison set it in his act
don't drive on sunset drive on fountain
yeah okay now
i remember one night having a drink and
being in the passenger side
and that person i was with was drinking
and seeing a cop at the same corner and
i lost my mind
like that's how much
it affects my alcohol system don't get
me wrong there was a couple bumps in my
pocket and i had a couple of bumps in my
nose i wasn't even driving but i almost
fell apart now
do you know how many times i've been at
that light on other nights when i was by
myself no cocktails in me no reefer in
my pocket a license everything's clean
and at that same light i'm talking about
i would take a grandma blow out of my
i would when i cop it mm-hmm i top right
there on fountain and three blocks
before fountain in la brea i know
exactly found in highland
fighting where's uh where's the [ __ ]
sandwich place with the french fries
uh yeah but then fought in the highlands
fountain in highland right there there's
a gas station and there's nothing i
could swear to my mother i could swear
to mercy
but i did this at least 300 times
because when you pull out of my old
dealer's house and you made it right
that's how i got home so i would make a
right by the time i made that right
george the gram i picked up was already
crumbled as soon as i got in the car i
would look around i would be straight as
an arrow
but i knew if a cop pulled up i had an
alibi he would always give me a cd or a
movie
or a cassette or a game there was always
something between us
and i always crushed the coke up real
fine and i cracked open the bindle so it
was ready to go so i would leave that
right there
and right there i would get a dollar
bill
and i would roll it up and i would
[ __ ] turn the car on
go up the fountain make a right and head
back to highland
because i always knew that light was
going to be red
if that light was green ooh would i get
pissed off lisa
why because i couldn't stop and do a
bomb
that light had to be red i would do two
miles an hour to make sure yeah that
light would be [ __ ] red lee how long
how long do you know me you know i get i
live by the green there's no red in my
life and if it's yellow i'm taking it
i'm taking a chance beeping the whole
time don't do it [ __ ]
don't do it [ __ ]
i would sit at that red light with one
car behind me and one car in front of me
two cars i would look to my right to see
who was in the gas station
and right there at that same
intersection i would put a [ __ ]
dollar bill in that package like holding
on to the thing and i'd make believe i
was going to sneeze and i go
that's you yeah and i look at that
package and i do three quarters of the
package right there just on the way home
right there at that i'd save that last
batch for after the first batch of
paranoia
and the first jerk off then i'd do that
one to get me through the night that's
the second back to jericho but i also
knew that at one o'clock
john would get off of work you know i'm
saying yeah there's another twenty yeah
there's another 40 i turn it to 18. i'll
give you 22 tomorrow
but uh you know i was talking to my
friend the other day and we used to uh
tweet together man and uh he turned
christian he's doing good man he's great
he's doing real good
and uh
he was like you remember that one time
we were all too he told me that we're i
guess we're on speed and we were like a
kickback you know kick back where girls
do it with you but people got money so
they're drinking and he says that i was
so tweaked out that if you know me i
grew myself a lot he said that i was
cutting my toenails in the living room
and in my head i was going
[ __ ] dog i was lost
you know what i mean like you were in a
bar cutting your fingernails no i was at
a party cutting my toenails in the
living room where everyone was tweaking
oh jesus christ that's the [ __ ]
that's that beats felipes ordering
spoons from room service
dog that was
tweaking
it's possibly to me now one of the
biggest embarrassments thank you i feel
the same way in my life yeah okay what
what's tweaking
okay so right now me you george my
friend here the beautiful miss
melissa samantha samantha melissa what
the [ __ ] samantha
right now george shows up and he brings
seven he has a quarter ounce of coke in
his pocket
for sale but he's got three and a half
grams
and because we're his friends
it's 11 o'clock right now 10 o'clock he
takes out a few lines and we do a few
lines and we got the refrigerator filled
with beer
hell yeah it's 10 43 whatever the [ __ ]
it is
9 43 right
was it 1003 now right here we're friends
paul is waiting for you
you got plans tomorrow 9 a.m
you got the gym at 12. you got another
podcast tomorrow at 3.
george has got an audition tomorrow at
2.
i have the baby tomorrow at nine it
doesn't matter george comes in
takes out a few lines we do him we drink
a beer
he puts our three more lines out we do
that we drink a beer or something we
look at each other and go george no more
be like come on what the [ __ ] i drove
all the way from orange county
we do another line of coke and now we
we're chatting
we're chatting
and next thing you know we look at the
clock it's two o'clock but there's six
more lines of coke there
and he just took out that little hostage
he was holding in his pocket he's not
going to charge us firstly we're family
he's got seven grams and it's two big
rocks one big brother and one little
cousin
he knows in the back of his mind that
samantha wants that little rock that's
how they're gonna rock and roll later on
so that goes in the side pocket a little
stash in this top little pocket up on
top with a couple xanax as he has in
there he probably has like an extra 10
xanax in his pocket because that's how
george runs and the collar dog in the
collar right so next thing you know lee
it's six in the morning
we have
10 beers left
there was two cases in there and that
nobody's touched for a month
there's 10 beers left you're figuring
out how to get beer right now on the
computer apollo's blowing you up the
only way we [ __ ] open that door is
for you to beat
beside that this room is filled with
cigarette smoke
okay
i mean it's just a horrible thing and
next thing you know it's nine in the
morning
and he still has half that rock in his
pocket
when we're not going nowhere people are
working around this the sun is out the
birds are chirping cars are pulling up
terry's calling me
god knows
paul is calling you your mom is calling
you she wants to ask you a question it's
ten o'clock
and now your shirt is off you're filled
with sweat
you've been smoking cigarettes even
though you don't smoke and you're
looking out windows because you thought
there was a cop out there when you went
to pee there was a [ __ ] looking
through the peephole
that's a complete different one that's
the beginnings of it that's only the
beginning that's the beginning of the
part of it then after about a year of
that you get to the point when george
comes over now and he does a line of
coke the first thing you do is get up
and lock the door
and then you check the windows
and then pretty soon your time you gotta
install a security camera outside
and you're sitting here at night with
the camera on watching doing coke with
your pants down watching you porn at the
same time
jerking off and watching the security
camera and jerking off you're sweating
you're drinking beer that's called
tweaking
i i have this apartment in my complex
who
their windows are it look i don't know
what it they use but it looks like they
just took wrapping paper and just went
from wall to wall they just like the
black wrapping paper something like that
they just taped it they just papered up
their windows what are they doing in
there
god knows jesus i want to know so bad
god knows but they could just be people
who don't like sunlight
somebody sleeps in there it could be
that but it it it becomes such a
horrible feeling lee
when it's seven in the morning
your day is ruined
and now you gotta stop and guess what
you're not stopping until that last rock
is gone no you got to keep alive and
you're pat you've already gone through
four hours of hiding
there comes a point where like one night
i got together with this buddy of mine
and i brought an ounce in there
beautiful cocaine it still cuts me like
a knife
georgia was shiny it was 1800 an ounce
at that time damn colorado
my deal was to pull an eight ball out
and throw 10 grams in and sell it for
100 a piece and leaf rocks in there yeah
you know i would grind it up but i'd
leave rocks in there so you 100 gram is
100 gram you know and the powder was
even good and me and this knucklehead
and my ex-wife go in there
and when i pull in i'm not i swear to
[ __ ] everything i i'm not high george
but when i pull in there i get out of
the car and i knew there were people
were talking to me about trying to i
look up and i see one of the curtains
open and closed like the little things
yeah and that stays in the back of your
mind straight up
it's so weird that that night as i was
driving up there i saw a cop double park
didn't affect me
but that stays in the back here mindly
the window first the car
then the window
so we both went in ah we're laughing his
girlfriend was there we're giggling we
take out this beautiful lounge we're
giggling we had this uh living room
situation there was a bathroom and then
there was this bedroom and we started
them and that's where our safe was
me and him shared that safe so i put my
coke up there at that time and then i
moved it to a different safe because
they knew especially after that night
so we went in there
all four of us we're drinking giggling i
whip out the ansleroo
we do two three four lines this is one
of the worst things ever
next thing you know me and this kid
start going nuts
you know we're working the [ __ ]
shades
wow and he's from the south he's from
north carolina
and he's like man there's somebody out
there
and now i'm out there you know yeah and
now and in my world if they're gonna
kick the door down this coat can't be
here so either we gotta snort this
[ __ ] soldier or we gotta [ __ ]
throw it away well guess what you know
me dawg
i started snorting that thing lee
in lines that would kill a mule and your
heart starts [ __ ] beating and you get
more paranoid and i'm looking around i'm
looking i'm hallucinating and i remember
i'll never forget at one point in the
night there's still a beautiful rock
left and like [ __ ] three grams of
powder and he yells because we between
the four of us the coke was so strong
you could not yeah nobody could do it
and i was i was doing quarter gram lines
and still not killing this mule face was
going i'm hallucinating right like i'm
seeing things and all of a sudden this
[ __ ] yells they got a dog
dog i run i take that [ __ ] coke i
open up that toilet i throw that rock
and i wash that thing and i flush that
toilet i wait for it to come up i clean
it off again
and that was it now we're [ __ ] high
and nobody's kicking in the door
yeah there's not even a dog after an
hour of us sweating
now we want to coke
there's no coke we're on our hands and
knees getting little crumbles
from the [ __ ] floor stick them in
your nose looking at each other
carpet and i'll never forget the sun
coming up and us finally opening up the
door
that dog
was a fire height
oh my god it was a fire hydrant but we
were both so high
we hallucinated
it was a dog where's tony bennett dog
i would never want you to tweet clean
i wouldn't want to either that point of
it gets
horrendously and painful
especially when you dump 1200 down the
toilet oh you're like what the [ __ ]
how are you feeling dog
i'm pretty good i'm good it's
do you want to keep it um
was that the most you've ever thrown
down the dream
no
no oh no
i tweaked a couple times to death like
one time i smoked the first time i
really really smoked crack
like it wasn't crack it was freebase at
the time
and that's the stuff
i was on probation i had a piss on
monday
and that was the last night my friends
were in town
they said no no no we're gonna cook in
the microwave we were in a hotel room in
boulder
and i took two hits of that and i ran
into the shower
and i wouldn't come out of the bathroom
for two hours in the tub
and when i finally came out i hid behind
the bed
did you understand me
yeah yeah i was a grown man hiding
behind the bed until it wore off
and then i joined them and played cards
or whatever the [ __ ] they were doing
they were howling their minds up
one night like so when my buddies came
from new york that time they came on a
monday
sorry
i got a kid
i'm so sorry that was the longest drive
i held there they came on that monday
i'm on probation
and the party was tuesday and wednesday
in aspen and then we were driving back
thursday and then we're gonna get a
hotel room
close to the airport and leave early
friday morning
so i wouldn't have done coke friday
saturday and sunday that was the plan so
i would have been clean for monday
okay
so so we have so much coke these guys
come out from jersey and they have so
much coke that that we do it tuesday and
wednesday but thursday night in this
hotel room they're like no dog i'll
never forget this choice they had a
balcony
like on the fourth floor
did it have like a rail on there or was
that it really was a beautiful bubble
you open up look onto the mountains and
[ __ ] and the airport was a mile away
i'll never forget that they go i came
out of the bathroom
and they said we cooked it in the
microwave and take a hit they were
playing cards
two of these idiots are playing cards
and they give me the pipe and i i'm like
come on give me a line i don't know try
this and i hadn't done this since 1982 i
didn't smoke coke
i took two heads
georgie went right to my head i ran into
the bathroom and i sat in the tub with
the curtains drawn
with the lights off for two hours then i
came out and i just hid behind the bed
and would talk to them and they go come
on from behind the bed then
it was you know george where does it
take your mind when you get to that
point
takes you to places you never knew you
could come out and get
now i've been there i mean i never
smoked rockwell not that i remember
but
man i i remember like you know like
listening to each other's story i want
to jump in but it's so like [ __ ] joke
it's weird like i love to do it the same
[ __ ] and like the way you narrated
tweaking right now i was like it's the
same and how loser you're gonna go look
at yourself in the mirror and see i'm
just scared
george lee
if we start doing coke at 10 o'clock at
night
when you come out of the mirror at four
you want another p if you look at your
face
it's the worst look you ever have on
your face
you anymore look at the mirror yeah yeah
you want to look at the mirror you you
you see
everything bad about you
like that's the worst feeling of the
night
that use all the bad [ __ ] that you never
comes out of you
is what you see addiction yeah
stupidity thoughts i'm a loser yeah
everything that's in you at that point
comes to the surface it's like uh
it's like [ __ ] you don't even know
that person is
and sometimes you cry
and
now you go do more culture
after you cry you go do more [ __ ]
coke like an [ __ ] that you are
because
i had done that before oh my god i lived
it i would cry you would cry to god this
is the last night i swear to god may god
take my life
i'll never do coke again after tonight
i'm a [ __ ] loser i gotta get my life
together i'm a regular at the comedy
store it doesn't matter with me and no i
go into that living room and i finish
that coke off and jerk off eight more
times
and then pass out and before lunch i'm
already thinking do i gotta get another
eight ball if i'm gonna stop
i gotta have a real party i can't leave
it like that yeah i've got a gram and a
half
if i'm gonna stop i gotta say a bon
voyage party it was
your mind was really just playing a
[ __ ] game with you man yeah i i had
to check myself because there became a
time where people were like
you know it's so hard to go to sleep
when you're on good coke it's [ __ ]
hard
so i started making myself throw up
because when you throw up the coat goes
away too like i only needed to be up
until that time
i was like you know it's one o'clock i
got to be responsible tomorrow you know
how you try to act like you cut corners
so i used to make myself throw up and i
would go to sleep
but then uh
it started getting scary man
so
this is the 19 in a row
then thanksgiving at the table i can say
thank you for [ __ ]
not letting me snort coke no more nah
dawg really really nine [ __ ] years
george i know i could never even think
of this time i never thought there was a
life
without doing blow like i didn't right
now when i suffer from like this
post-traumatic [ __ ] and i gotta tell you
you know what it is i figured out this
weekend i was taking a shower
even at 18 i figured out
if you know that blow
there's no reason to go out
like i i'm not lying to you guys why am
i in high school when i was a senior in
high school i had already in my mind
these girls are going to be there
these dudes are going to be there i'm
going there for one [ __ ] reason
straight up so if i ain't got no coke i
don't have the advantage
yeah i'm not a handsome dude i got to go
in this late night with coke and lure
him back to the apartment alla cosby and
[ __ ] all [ __ ] up and then when they
get there show me your tits and then the
next thing you know you got them upside
down and you put coke rocks in their ass
the next week they're giving you dirty
looks at the bar like they don't know
who you are and [ __ ] you forgot me
straight up what happened that [ __ ]
freak show you did last tuesday what was
that there's no love there
but that was it in my mind i remember
friday night staying in because i had
the money for the coke
but what night should i go out friday or
saturday you know
back to like uh you you're telling me
how like you're at the hotel and almost
got raided have you ever been in a place
that's been raided
like or like around it like i remember i
was at a hotel like because you know all
the hotel rooms are doing it too
you think it's just you because
everyone's do i remember there was a
hotel room that got raided right by us
and it [ __ ] shocked the [ __ ] that was
just the little what's the young hotel
in vegas the tip
where they used to have the hard rock
yes that's the [ __ ] crazy one with
the crate that's the hotel where
everybody's doing blood yeah and what
you do is i've told people you say if
you're a lonely guy that's the hotel for
you
you wait
professional you gotta be a professional
all right if you want to be a [ __ ]
amateur and go out and jump up and down
if she's with six girls and i want to
hit on samantha i'm not going to lure
from the five girls there's one girl in
there that's gonna go no samantha he's
not for you remember what happened with
chucky you know you know there's always
one lady who's gonna score your night
even though you like me we work next to
each other i got an eight ball a blow
you know what i'm saying it's been a
while since you left the house
you're trying to get your [ __ ] together
it's very tough so why would i go that
route
i love when guys like wait wait wait
this girl's gonna go home you're gonna
she's not going nowhere bro she's got
three girls around she leaves she's the
first [ __ ] we got a little two of them
and they don't like me i'm the ugly one
so i'm in no danger you're in no danger
if there was two good looking guys then
both of them don't look bad leaving
cause at least one i can't believe
samantha she's yeah but so did gina all
right let's go have a good time maybe
you guys should go look for a [ __ ]
man so do you understand me so what you
do is at the hard rock is you go to bed
nice and early
you're like a grandma blow but you bring
like two xanaxes again on friday night
you go to bed at nine you watch like
uh a family show or something someone
abc family
bro you you set that alarm for 3 30 am
that's when it cracks
you take a shower you put on your
[ __ ]
genome machete shirt
and you go right downstairs to the
24-hour cafe and watch the [ __ ] bird
come to the [ __ ] cat
oh yeah you just make them believe
you're reading the menu and they'll come
right up to you how are you are you
sitting here alone all [ __ ] up and
right there at the table before they
even know that
what type of party is this do we have a
future together or
are you waiting for somebody because i
got a rock a coke that looks like a pot
he said parmesan cheese to the table you
see that rock in there how it gets hard
i got a coke rock bigger than that
now what do you want to do you want to
go home with a story or you want to go
up to your room lonely with your six
other loser buddies up there passed out
with no shoes on
what do you want to do and dog
they [ __ ] lure i'm not a good looking
guy i didn't even have blow but i saw
the waitress there from whatever and i
lured her to the bedroom with aspen
cause you always got to bring heart
medication with you that bare aspen the
white [ __ ] you grind that down you snort
that at four in the morning when you're
drinking you don't know what you're
snorting
you gotta be a professional you know
what i'm saying
oh my god i could never go back to
duke's after that
i remember we did snort that one time it
was like the burn of burns huh what did
we snow at that time
no not me and you i remember i did it
i've never done it with you
no two thousand yeah because when we did
whatever was 2007 2006. we did it in
2006. it's hysterical because they paid
me they gave us a hotel room
i made it back from san bernardino in 15
minutes i was at the whitley cashing
check on hollywood boulevard cashing
that 2500
i went right to the drug dealers i think
you know cause there's different moods
when you go to drug dealers house
sometimes you have to go timid like hi
how you doing yeah what's the matter
i've had a rough day listen
let me get a gram i only got 42.50 i'll
give you another 17.50 and he gives you
a lecture yeah
dog you can't be doing this [ __ ] to me i
ain't no [ __ ] bank you know who you
think you know who you think you're
dealing with you're like i like you
[ __ ] that's 200 you owe me all
right
all right
but then there's times you have money to
cover it now you're a little bit more
flamboyant
let's say he's black you call him the
n-word and [ __ ] what's up
you know saying
you're all clean you go there give him
the 60 for the g note yeah and you leave
but when you got deep pocket [ __ ]
you're going in there telling him how
shitty he is coke let me tell you
something i don't need this [ __ ] i'm
doing you a favor all right
give me the good [ __ ] from under the bed
this is the [ __ ] you sell the puerto
ricans and [ __ ] like right or wrong yeah
when you walk into a drug dealer with
deep pockets you're giving orders let me
get a selfie hey wait this [ __ ] again go
away this [ __ ] have you ever seen the
opening scene
late put the [ __ ] thing on
put the [ __ ] get the youtube red i
got to show jordan what is it what is it
click in king of new york opening scene
in new york oh
oh i'm gonna show you a masterpiece
this is how you show up to a drug
dealer's house okay okay i'm gonna show
you something that nobody's ever seen
before if it was my world this guy would
have
should have won
the academy or lee what are we doing
here i'm doing strike the computer up i
don't see a screen i don't see nothing
you're playing with my emotions
i gotta see it so i can show it to you i
used to always show up to the drug
dealer's house with like old ass dvds oh
yeah when you used to show up with
[ __ ] sweatshirts and [ __ ]
yo man i know you don't wear size nine
jordans though but somebody does
all right
let's read it from the top
for the bullet holes welcome back frank
uh we got to get busy king of new york
jumps versus tito yeah that one
the first one uh whatever here's for the
bullet holes
go for that one i'm gonna show you an
education ladies and gentlemen
this you never seen this no
click this out loudly
oh yes i have seen this this is og this
is why he should when this is why he's
one of the best black doctors working
today you never saw this no this is what
i'm saying but you got time to go watch
i was too young harry potter this is
this is an academy award-winning
presentation by lawrence fishburne
in the beginning of king of new york hit
it lee
oh
lawrence fishburne
now watch
leave this league
[Music]
he's complaining about i'm not having a
soda at first that's how you walk into
the drug dealer's house when you got
money
watch this
where's my shoulder
[Music]
room service [ __ ]
that's joey diaz early that's what i was
trying to be right there
oh my god
watch this one i'm watching one too
watch this one too this is this is the
man playing [ __ ] uh frank white
[Music]
is that robin gibbon
no that's the other black girl from the
80s that was badass
now this is like the [ __ ] best hotel
in new york league
all right this is after they shoot
whatever his name is king tito whatever
we're watching king of new york
damn he's young
look at the guy behind them all these
[ __ ] are still around
what's in a cup
root beer
look at obama in the left
it's obama when he was an extra
there's some things i don't do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the dude on the on the left tried to rob
him on the train
and he gives him a job
[Music]
[Applause]
this is way before he danced on saturday
night live dog
congratulations frank check him out
congratulations man colombian
[ __ ] they took permanent
vacation in hell if you know what i mean
well i must have been away too long
because my feelings are dead
i am i feel no remorse yo
it's a terrible thing
yeah i heard being in jail makes you
feel like that man
that's a beautiful [ __ ] movie lee you
got to watch this this is cool this is
on hbo like
and it goes on for like four months and
then they they yank it you don't see it
for five years
but when you watch it every time
it gets stronger you watch like 30
minutes here and then you go to bed then
you come home one night it's on
from that [ __ ] part you know it's
pretty weird how it works out
but i don't even know what we're talking
about how's the edible hitting you
thought was hitting me oh my god this is
tremendous those [ __ ] we ate the
chocolate bar those taffys were pretty
good yeah that's happening
is always good well the taffy's but then
where we eat the toffee things that
toffee thing they sell them for 10 bucks
it's 250 milligrams
you know when i go there sometimes
they give me 20 30 off so i just tell
them like give me a couple things give
me that give me this give me that
it's like 100 bucks bang i walk out of
there one day i eat a rice krispie treat
which does nothing to me i just like the
flavor of it
and then about an hour later i eat the
[ __ ] crispy thing
and i go but about my day and about two
o'clock george perez
i'm sitting somewhere and i'm hearing
sirens and
[ __ ] oh like oh my god it's starting to
go like i'm starting to [ __ ] lose it
this is it
and finally i realized i had eaten that
thing
i was high
burning for like three hours like i ate
the whole bar
and i was burning the first time you eat
an edible to different
whatever part of the seed or whatever i
don't [ __ ] know yeah it's you you're
never been that high it's kind of we're
bringing stars back tomorrow we get the
stars at 11 o'clock
tomorrow night we'll eat 10 stars apiece
me and him that's a thousand milligrams
because each thc is different than those
stars he did an experiment this weekend
that i knew what he was going to tell me
i told him before he told me
that we eat those things those cushies
they're 200 milligrams okay those 200
milligram four little glue things
they will [ __ ] you up like a pill but
what's like the red what's the regular
thing like what are you supposed to eat
if you're new 15 10 20 yeah
30 40 50 maybe
vicky pez's uh boyfriend ate 60
milligrams the amount of chocolate
you should have seen him
fell out or goofy no he just was he
didn't know where he was he was there
with us
he was outside smoking like faking the
funk i felt bad for him but not really
he wasn't like
you know
you know and the experiment you were
saying is i had so what happened was i
wanted a bunch of the 200s they were out
of them so they sold me the hundreds for
the same price
so i had three of the hundreds and i got
[ __ ] up
gone [ __ ] up you got to get up and eat
something yeah that's the stuff that's
worse [ __ ] you know my wife bought those
little sandwich you know like you have
ice cream sandwiches yeah like
ones for mercy okay dog
i ate ten of them
she woke up she goes there's rappers
everywhere what happened
i said you can't buy those things i'm
gonna diet i come in at 12 o'clock from
two hours with lee we [ __ ] 20 000
milligrams and you want to get [ __ ]
ice cream sandwiches i ate there i got
up sat down got upset i was like a
[ __ ] yo-yo and i finally took four of
them out now you're committed you know
what i'm saying
i just finished the box i just threw the
whole box away i'm thinking about my
daughter now in the morning i gotta go
to rouse and buy a box of these and i
hope she didn't get them from target i
gotta go to [ __ ] victory
this hotel did have one of those little
stores though with the candies
i didn't get any because i get paranoid
when i get high i don't want anyone to
know but how much money do you guys
spend when you get stoned on the road at
those hotel stores nothing no you don't
do it
yeah i'll go to i'll go get some food
i avoid that
thing downstairs yeah me too i'll get a
water i'll get a soda the only thing i
get to splurge
on a friday night if i have to wake up
saturday is trail mix
the peanut people me can make a little
bag of trail mix and i take that
upstairs to my room after i'm high and i
eat those
and i'm good for the night
some hotels they kill you with the chips
and [ __ ]
you know some hotels have real [ __ ]
food which isn't bad but you know what
man
it's a process for me nah nah nah
because the they root the room service
like when we went to that place last
week we would have spent the night
that's 24 hour room
service well at foxwoods yeah that was
24-hour room service and they got a
tremendous menu at three in the morning
i'm talking about an open turkey
sandwich i looked at it
god damn 24 hours i get an open turkey
sandwich vegas
when we go to vegas that's 24 hour room
service so you don't really have to eat
[ __ ] you get a salad at four in the
morning you know
i haven't bought you 85
but you re
you're eating
sorry about that no you're good i'm
[ __ ] starving
right now i go for like four potato
tacos right now if that [ __ ] is
open we miss both of them lee we can't
even hit moore park right now oh
grasshoppers
they close at 11 and [ __ ] the lord's
day where's some taco eating
[ __ ] me and lee they got a
lisa employee of the month down the
block on burbank they took a picture of
him one night he had so many tacos i i i
had to get behind there and help out
they were busy on taco tuesday he knew
exactly what they were doing oh yeah
another order did you eat some tacos and
pismo beats that tarzan no we didn't we
went to the place uh let me tell you
something but without even telling you
right now and this is my witness
when you drive up
to any of those towns and you pull over
to get gas there's always like a food
truck
and you go up to that food truck lee
and you will get the best tacos you've
ever had in your life on the way to
visalia
the only thing about the gig was that
like three exits up
once you hit the 170 or the five it is
the 170 is it no it can't because it
ends
it's the thrive
once you under five and head ups north
like after four stops you'll see a gas
station and there's a little thing that
sits next to it it's well known you know
you're going to ask darren carter
darren carter lives at that place
because i've had discussions with him
about that taco place
lee [ __ ] phenomenal anyway you see
mexican farmers picking grapes and [ __ ]
oh yeah i'm sure there's a taco stand
and those tacos
are off the hook you know why
because they're selling to authentic
mexicans
they're not selling to [ __ ] these
gentile mexicans that you know they
don't speak spanish and [ __ ] and all
that they're up there with the real deal
so they got to show up with the real do
you pull over they're 50 cents
you'll die you go what the [ __ ] i mean a
cat
joey better not find that you go you
know what if it's a cat i'm getting ten
of these [ __ ]
they're delicious
my delicious dog oh every route up there
i don't know exactly where because me
and marilyn used to do the uh ventura
club
okay 15 years ago on friday nights they
would give us 100 bucks to drive to
ventura to do the gig but 20 of that bro
taco we would stop at a place right off
the [ __ ] thing that you thought you
were gonna get mugged in it was like a
beat up gas station and three miles not
even
200 yards down was like a little hut
oh my god
oh my god lee you didn't get sick
and the service
was impeccable cleanly
clean
i found a spot off the five in indiana
by commerce there you go there's a gas
station and this family just they
they live at the house next to the gas
station and they got a kitchen i i know
you're going to say it's a yelp thing
but we found it on yelp but it's our new
favorite mexican place in the valley
it's in the gas station which by the way
is the stoner heaven it has literally
every snack you could ever imagine think
of or never thought of every chip flavor
but this mexican food restaurant that is
amazing
it's like the it's the best but we go
there probably
more home we're in town probably every
sunday
and what do you get uh there's a brew
there's this uh carne asada burrito
which i like they have a california
burrito but that has fries and they put
bacon in that but but you have to be
careful with that one because they put
buffalo sauce on it so you have to say
no to that you have to say no you have
to say no to that
[ __ ] mexican
mexican food it's like a snack
i promise you it's good barbecue and
bacon you're saying i deal with it it's
like [ __ ]
it's like a [ __ ] nightmare and you
know what sucks about this the worst
that his girlfriend is mexican and she
eats that [ __ ] no it's good she allows
it it's got bacon and [ __ ] what's he
talking about can you please talk to him
it's good i promise i'm not even [ __ ]
mexican
and i don't know what the [ __ ] he's
talking about buffalo sauce
what are you talking about for christ's
sakes i think it's called cali talking
yeah you're confused dog please yeah
please i know it's got cheese and that's
why you know no no they put a ton of
cheese okay it's gotta be cheese or
french fries there's gotta be some
[ __ ] thing in there authentic please
let me know how much you're gonna do
please
leave me alone sherman way please leave
me alone already please check it out
i've seen people there from the podcast
yeah i know i know other [ __ ] morons
no they're not no no they're going to be
a barbecue [ __ ] sauce
buffalo sauce okay this is what i'm
saying and there's in the white and then
when he's supposed to eat buffalo sauce
he gets barbecue on his wings i don't
get the bubbles on that burrito this is
what i'm talking about by the way he
goes to a place where they put buffalo
sauce on burritos i'm done the
counseling is done he's on his own he's
experimental he's he's it's just amazing
what i got to live with i don't put on
all the burritos no i know just the
thought that they put it on a burrito
yeah that's it that's where the party
ends
we it's called salsa it's so long
especially when you're mexican you walk
in there and go they put buffalo sauce
for a burrito get in the car and then
you eat it you get a [ __ ] car what
are you crazy yeah we gotta go no don't
buy a soda get in the [ __ ] car this
is what i'm dealing with doug it's
amazing
there's not even like a two and two like
it don't even hit i could take them to
king taco i could take them no i'm
saying king taco as a general i could
take them to [ __ ] where uh gabe
gilbert lives
in in uh long beach
no gilbert esquivel lives in long beach
next to delaware
i'm not gonna lie
i'll take you for mexican food leader
your hair will grow in front of you
and this guy will go to that same dump
the next day and eat after he just ate
the best in the world
he will lower down and go to a gas
station and look me in the face
and tell me it's a good place we're
talking about professional places here i
promise people who sell food to mexican
people there's right now
no they're not not they're putting
buffalo sauce in the [ __ ] time they
don't get that one oh i know
they have it it's like i said to you if
you come to my table and you bring uh
ranch dressing with you i get up either
i get up or you got to get up we're not
in the same world
that's it we'll come back well they put
bacon in one burrito oh it's good 30
years i've never seen bacon on a burrito
never never in all my life i lived in
colorado i lived in [ __ ] but never in
a burrito yeah and buffalo sauce never
in a burrito never all my [ __ ] life
and i've dealt with the prison mexicans
that they get the taco sent in the
burrito something not once the only
thing they get don't use maybe we put it
in our beans with bacon yeah you know
but not yes i put those beans in that
burrito leave me alone
i love this though like he really thinks
he's like hey dog i'm telling you this i
promise you it's good bro two months ago
he wanted to start a business
about magazine articles like it's called
cnn no it's not no it's not no it's not
i'm not saying this idea because it's a
good goddamn idea i know no no this is
you know what he was trying to rob next
issue no we do that venture whatever
it's called he was trying to rob them
and you know and he sat there for a hour
and i'm like you're college educated
this is everything
this is everything lovely
i love them to death hey i'm going to
try that burrito now no you're not you
should try that right now even walking
go to that look it up on you up on
you're on your way home look at him he
loves you of course i love you everyone
the only place on sherman way is that
place where they sell the [ __ ] hot
beans yeah and then you can't stop there
no you can't park there there's a line
out the door all the time be prepared
you got to go there at 1101. who wants
to eat at 1101 you do because you've
been smoking dope since 8. oh my god and
you already worked out and you went home
and washed your questions
you go before the lunch crowd you go to
11 20 before the line comes at 12. you
don't go at 12 when everybody else is
there you wait till 1 30 now now you
have a protein shake and you wait till
one [ __ ] 30. that's how normal
[ __ ] professionals eat
okay if not i'm competing with 80 other
gorillas then you wonder why they put
red sauce into the green sauce
i go in there when it's nice and empty i
don't want nobody hearing what i got to
say
i'm the same way i don't want nobody
hearing what i want to say i want lunch
i go 11 20.
you're going to go to chinese restaurant
11 20. they look at you weird like
nobody else is here yeah give a [ __ ]
that's why i'm here
they don't even have that from now on
i'm the new sheriff in town 11 20 to 11
30. i'll be coming in here and i want
this [ __ ] table right here and
they'll look at you like this
[ __ ] for real and that's the
fresh batch you get the nice batch it's
the fresh [ __ ] meat it hasn't been
sitting there all [ __ ] things that's
how professionals yeah the vegetables
you get up at [ __ ] six you have a
nice breakfast you smoke 15 joints and
by 11 if you're a [ __ ] normal you're
ready to eat your hand
by 11 15 you're like i got 45 more
minutes to wait why wait let even if i
had a job i talked the boss into either
going early
or going at 1 30.
what do you mean like let's say i had a
job
lunch was 9 to 12
and 1 to 6.
i'd pay a doctor 20 bucks to write me a
note that said how to either eleven
because if not my blood sugar goes down
it's some [ __ ] you gotta be creative
yeah no you do okay you gotta be [ __ ]
you can't be a [ __ ] but you don't wanna
sit you don't wanna go to lunch with
these eight morons and says the same
table and talk about your job all over
again for a [ __ ] hour
you want an hour to yourself so you tell
them you got to go to 11 or you got to
go out one if you got to go at one then
you bring a snack you bring a ham and
cheese sandwich at 11. and you [ __ ]
eat it right there at your desk which is
not a snack it's a snack whatever it
holds you over
it holds you over but the whole time
you're thinking about that lunch special
you're like i can't wait to go in there
and get the hot and sour soup with the
[ __ ] number two with the egg roll and
the [ __ ] noodles and i'm gonna get
the pork fried rice today with the
shrimp and lobster sauce and then
instead of the rainbow sherbet today i'm
getting the orange sherbet because last
time the rainbow sherbet was suspect
hey joey have you ever been to like an
asian restaurant that you didn't like
i could because i've been so good at
reading them it's very weird the only
places i've been taking is right here in
this neighborhood
oh because everybody else says go in
there and try it out
and you know what these places probably
have one or two really good dishes
but everything else blows i don't even
trust the chicken at these places yeah
it's always got like it's always skinny
like it feels like a cat's i pet my cats
and i know what that skin feels like i
really do i know what you mean please
don't say i'm eating cat because i've
been eating cats
monsters and monkeys for years
that's why you're all clogged up and
[ __ ] i'm not clogged up yes you are
that's why the tushy don't work oh it's
just your mom
you eat up them down that laurel can you
thai food
you eat at the tacos with lizards god
knows
you poisoned your dad paula ate that
[ __ ] pork or shrimp
you guys just did that poison nobody you
take shots at places that nobody is
taking shots at you at a reasonable
place why because you listen to it 100
reviews or more i don't take nothing
unless it's him
if he comes to me and goes bro me and my
me and samantha went to this cuban place
and they make the thing how you like
with the chorizo that's who i listen to
yeah i listen to you too you listen to
me yeah you know uh joey anybody i tell
you what's the best bang for your buck
i shorten it down i take a long sentence
yeah but you don't like him anything
hey felipe does know some dope spots
cause he's been in the hood
here
you listen to people like that that's
who i listen to if i don't get a
personal review from them that
restaurant will not exist in my [ __ ]
life
remember that like john it was like a
ghetto jamba juice by his house on union
and temple like when he looked downtown
yeah yes that was it was a filipino dude
oh that [ __ ] [ __ ] was bomb
he knows people know you know you got to
trust people who really know food i need
a skinny guy that he's [ __ ] kale to
tell me what's good that's who's going
to go on yelp
i want a fat [ __ ] it's like when you go
to a restaurant you see a skinny chef
like he's got aids i don't eat that
if he was so [ __ ] good he'd he beat
his own food
every chef you see is a fat [ __ ]
sweating drinking beer behind the line
that's the chef i want the guy that
looks like he's about to have a heart
attack
that's the chef that you want right
there that's a [ __ ] that's
eating his own food he believes in it
when you go to [ __ ] chick-fil-a you
don't see those people eating her own
food i was watching those people the
other morning i heard that's good though
is it true chick-fil-a yeah
maybe 20 [ __ ] years ago now okay i
went one i went twice on sunset and both
times i felt sick i had to take a [ __ ]
right away
no no no no that's just shitty [ __ ]
food the other day i was in houston i
got tacos but i sat down and watched the
chinese people at that place what's the
poppy the one that has the chain
at all the places and express panda
express i don't [ __ ] with that that rice
looks a little petrified i got up and
looked at it and [ __ ] with the
headlights their noodles look like
they're on speed i used to get the
chicken egg rolls from them not bad to
hold you over but not a real leg while
it breaks apart in your mouth but
when you're a [ __ ] uh sap you gotta
eat what you gotta yeah you're 400
pounds no i hate that [ __ ] no more okay
so this weekend
no didn't even touch it
had uh i want to eat chinese food at
that place well they won't even let us
in the door that place by the sunset
room
uh i don't know about that place george
they won't serve us i know but that i
think it's that good but they don't give
a [ __ ] about us no they're playing cards
in the back they're ganging in the back
and they're probably stabbing 10 chinese
people on the back that don't pay their
debt oh my god that's why i'm right
every time you go over there
that was one of my all-time favorite
rooms i always wished
in my perverted comedy mind that the
sunset room would become this thing like
a 200 seater
with that bar with that stage yeah yeah
i could see an hbo special getting shot
there because it has that like lava
style like i really believed in that
place on monday nights but he had no
respect for comedy
and that pissed me off yeah max
it was a cash register thing for him and
even when there was people in there
because of the comedy he wasn't happy he
wasn't happy
you know he would give you a plate of
fried [ __ ] food that tasted like
[ __ ] the bartender had it her ass
and the monday night the girl had no
personality she wouldn't talk to you
remember she was good looking she had a
blonde streak in her head oh yeah she
but she was a [ __ ] weird as [ __ ]
wouldn't communicate you could temper a
five or ten
wouldn't communicate with you but i
still believed in the place but it was
across the street from a kentucky fried
chicken biggest bucket in the world 30
yards from
a donut place that was delicious yeah
the doughnuts
30 yards from a chinese place that would
not cater to us when we went there at
night
they would make believe they only spoke
chinese in the restaurant was closed
but the place would be surrounded packed
cars
and there would be not one person eating
at the restaurant
not one lee
where were they in the back gambling
playing cards
killing people whatever the [ __ ] they do
on tuesday wednesdays and monday nights
and chinese i don't [ __ ] know i don't
did you ever play pool and hustle like
that okay i played pool
and he's my i was terrible paul beat me
all three times my mother had a bar
and when she cut the kitchen out
they put a pool table in that i was
about the age of six and i started
[ __ ] around and they just put george
they cut the kitchen out they're like
we're not selling food more drinks no
more
and my mom got a pool table and i was
about six and uh that's why i started
playing pool and people taught me
different things
and by the age of nine or ten dog george
i wasn't bad yeah plus you was in east
coast but this was the problem it was
the first thing i had fallen in love
with
oh i got it as a child
so when you would break my balls i would
challenge you
and when i won i would go overboard and
when i lost i would lose my [ __ ] mind
and say [ __ ] oh
and then what kind of [ __ ] like some
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
like the first time it happened i had to
be maybe about 10 and at my mother's bar
and i was playing an adult that was a
family friend
and he cleaned the table off on me
and i started calling him a [ __ ] and
he didn't know how to handle it yeah
you're a [ __ ] punk everybody thinks
you're a [ __ ] you're cheap and these
are things i overheard people say about
him in confidence okay and my mother
smacked me in the [ __ ] mouth and made
me go in the office and that was the end
of that tune
i apologize two weeks later but the guy
never came around again
and then about a year later and this one
still to this day still wants me in fact
his cousin just sent me a picture
i grew up
with this family the guy's name was
machito machito what's that from he's a
cuban dude okay
he had skin like me
beautiful man about five foot ten built
and he had a kid he got on the weekends
his name was julie
julian julian was his name
and his cousin was martin perez a kid
i'm still friends with on facebook he
was his father was batista's driver
and did you guys know each other from
cuba or we knew each other from grammar
school like early on okay we knew each
other we were family friends
machito
sold coke in the 70s and he was friends
with my mom
and he was a good dude to me he drive me
to met games and [ __ ] i became friends
with machito and he hung out at this bar
on the corner of 57th and hudson the
guy's name was fellow f he hello who ran
it and as a child at the age of 11
because he didn't have julie all the
time he considered me one of his boys so
he would take me to baseball games and
buy me bats and he would smoke dope in
front of me whatever and i would never
repeat any of that stuff
so i became friends with julie
me and julie were tight in the summers i
hung out to get anybody to go back to
miami or his mother lived in the bronx i
can't remember the exact story
but i was pretty good at pool
and one day we're at that bar i believe
in front of my mom my stepdad
all my mom's friends
my d you know not martin perez wasn't
there but julie was then his father who
always very good to me
and julie beat me in the first hand
smash you or smash me
and i went nuts on
and then i started doing diaz brothers
things as i was playing them i would say
[ __ ] to him and bait him yeah
and he lost the second game and then he
lost the third game but i had already
settled those things
we were still friends for a while and
then he went to miami his parents moved
to miami and
10 years ago i found out he didn't even
make it to 21. correct
crack took him in miami
right away
and i had a chance to apologize to him
he was like family at my house he would
come over and swim in the pool and we'd
play baseball and i gave him clothes and
[ __ ]
but uh i don't think that that wound
never really healed and i live with that
today it's
damn
what are you gonna do you know what i'm
saying that's why you gotta sometimes
keep on pushing
well sometimes you gotta be careful i
was a young kid
but i learned from that lesson that i
couldn't fall in love with something
that much
that's why i could never really be a fan
of a football team or something because
i'm the one that punches you in the
[ __ ] head yeah and i'm saying i can't
commit that much i'll [ __ ] you up if you
talk [ __ ] on my mind
so before that happens i just eliminate
that thing because
some people take it really for real but
you know what in in boxing it's a whole
[ __ ] different [ __ ] like i noticed
like you don't even have to like sports
boxing is like backing you up
it's like if you're down for a fighter
you'll fight another person
you ever been like that what do you mean
like say chivas was fighting someone
who's your favorite boxer
i'm talking when you're 21 though when i
was a kid i really liked boxing but it
was a different world
i grew up in a time with with you know
benitez and duran
oh yeah you know i grew up boom boom
mancini
i was i was at the chiropractor doing
one of those jute falls
when i hurt my shoulder in 82
i had a what what i had to do was is was
raise bills up so you could sue the
doctor you could sue like let's say you
fell down the stairs
and you go to hospital and you try to
sue me you ain't gonna get [ __ ] yeah
because you just got a hospital bill you
gotta go to the hospital and get therapy
that means for a year you can't go to
work
you gotta go in every day with a neck
brace on and they'd look at you and go
you're making progress meanwhile you're
jerking off with both arms you're
playing the drums you're playing darts
at the bar you know what i'm saying
so i was raised the jewish attorney told
me because to get the most money you got
to go to the doctor every day yeah it's
like punching it so basically go to the
doctor he put electrodes on me give me a
little massage and i'd leave
but the day he fought boom boom mancini
when i walked out of the office
nobody was listening to the phone
everybody was watching this fight
and i he thought do come kim
oh that's okay i'll go ahead and he went
the thing about duke and kim that always
shocked everybody was
that on the on the mirror there was wood
around it
and he wrote something really
fascinating like
kill or be killed
uh
yeah he wrote something he knew in the
back of his mind
it was this was going to be a fight lee
you weren't even conceived i was fired
you weren't even a thought in your
daddy's pants
this was when there was no real
pay-per-view this was a fight on wild
world of sports on five o'clock on a
saturday afternoon
and it was january it was cold
i went into this doctor's office i
remember having a jacket and sitting
down
and it was the seventh round or
something i have no idea but when i
walked out i had never seen two guys
beating each other like that
they would just leave this went on for
however many rounds
and then the guy dropped and died in the
ring
what
look it up see if it's on youtube real
quick
oh it has to be boom boom mancini
against
do come kim the end
where was he from duke kung kim korea he
was korean korean he wrote something on
the mirror etched it like killer be
killed
this was a battle lee at the middle of
the afternoon
there were fighting in the daytime like
a fight was a daytime fight this was a
daytime fight i don't forget being at
the doctor's office oh
was it like an open stadium let's see
let's let's see if i remember correctly
what's the problem
oh i thought i was using the right
keyboard
write down boom boom mancini and watch
that's the first thing that'll come up
probably uh
sure we're gonna watch someone die
why not when's the last time you seen
somebody [ __ ] go down i don't make a
habit of it you put some stairs on me in
front of eight in the morning watch me
go down
there it is you called it out first one
dooku kim right there what the [ __ ] you
think you're dealing with some novice
here
1982 son who the [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with
wha which one do i'm gonna do i don't
know
the the middle one's only 10 minutes
and we can't watch the whole thing i
just want them to show two minutes three
minutes just so see and everybody else
can learn the intensity of this fight i
would i would play the bottom one the
bottom play the bottom one the fourth
one there you go
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah but look at him
look at kim's face oh man oh [ __ ]
he's gonna die
yeah he died minutes later
[ __ ] he went down and look at the guy's
face though he was [ __ ] looking at
this dude's face oh jesus christ
that's when you get hit with a pipe and
[ __ ]
cops get there they don't know what to
do with you
oh stand right there sir sit down sit
down
do you feel anything do you feel dizzy
i'm just seeing things right now
so what do you got going on george
what's coming up next for you oh you
always got something cracking you know
hey dawg i learned from you brother i
stay hosting uh russell peters is
awesome enough to let me open up for him
at the break improv
the november 1st 2nd and 3rd
and then on the
6th 7th and eighth
i am with um
i'm doing the mangria tour
and when does that start and that's a
band you and redman yeah and ryan dune
that's december
8th phoenix at the last exit live
december i'm sorry that's december 6
phoenix last exit live december 7th
vegas
the beauty bar on december 8th winston's
nice man it's cool yeah it's it's not
like a huge venue so i i kind of like
hey i'm starting off man you know how
many minutes do you do
sometimes they let me do 40. sometimes i
just do 20 or me and red men will flip
he'll do 40 i'll do 20. we
just into one of these venues and think
about
like 10 years ago i was in the cell
and here i am at a [ __ ] venue
and i know people that can't get out of
their own [ __ ] wing you got to feel
bad about yourself
but it's so weird how i get that ever
that's how fortunate i am a couple weeks
ago i'm at the wilbur [ __ ] theater
with lena i walk up to the stage and i
got the worst anxiety i've ever gotten
that was one of the things that went
through my mind
that these people knew where i was from
a point in my life would they still come
here that him saying like yeah it still
trips with me yeah even though i paid my
debt and stuff so but at the end
it's a great feeling when you're in your
hotel room and you go i did it yeah and
nobody knew what i'm saying unless i
told them nobody knew
it's my secret but i let them out to
them and now
i feel a lot better about myself in a
way you know
tomorrow's uh seven years since i've
been out of prison see that yeah that's
why today was my nephew's birthday and i
got out of prison i was i got out of
prison the day after my nephew was born
and we went to his party today i just
dude i just realized because you're
talking about it's been seven years so
there's a reason why you were supposed
to be here tonight my brother said no
it's been crazy [ __ ] years i've been
out knock on wood man let me give you
some shout outs real quick lee how you
feeling [ __ ]
sam summers my man dom de niro
patrick c wright
rachel lee little showed up to the show
my girl melissa eva perez
gave me some information bobby and
crystal down there john cutler and amy
my man leon
and jeremy slagoth you know i love you
as you know wednesday night
irvine improv 8 pm show you out of there
by 10 you go see your college buddies
jump up and down we got stars we're
gonna get nice and stoned you know us
and then the following week two weeks
after that it's uh
portland oregon helium [ __ ]
and that's basically it my brother
i'm happy you came out tonight to
celebrate seven years there's a reason
god put you in here tonight yes
you know always just to follow up with
you yeah hey man i love it that you do
it man cause i saw you on corolla
and i was like look at this [ __ ] he's
getting i know you did burt and people
loved john burke you were on here a
month ago people loved you they still
get little questions about you so what
the [ __ ] this is a great way your
thanksgiving week you know i'm grateful
yeah i'm [ __ ] so grateful bro every
time i hit that
you're back in irvine too healthy yeah
one night irvine bing bang and i got the
weekend with my family i think i'm at
the store saturday maybe i don't know
you know manchester you got the eggnog
ready do i have the eggnog ready i am
possibly most excited christmas i'm
about to have
with this little [ __ ] girl yeah
okay
pretty much done
after the fourth
the special premieres on c so don't
forget
code word joey code word joey and you
get two months for free so if you get it
today you come until january 1st they
got great programming i would not
[ __ ] you they really do they're
going to take over this whole [ __ ]
comedy business watch them so i'm really
happy to be a part of them i'm giving
you ceso for free right now for two
months go to cesotv and preston joey
that's it that's how easy that [ __ ]
is
and after that i'm pretty much done
you know i i committed to this special
and i got some engagements now that come
up i can't do this movie i had a movie i
was gonna do four days
but these the next two days they want me
to do a bunch of promotional [ __ ] like i
can't ask them to
change it you know so
yeah so you have to [ __ ] shift around
which will make me work on the book a
little more
which i'm still miles away from where i
need to be but if but do you feel like
you scratch the surface on it yet like
yes yes
i really want to know i i have three
books instead of one really
you know i look at this material like
this who parked the bonus
this is uh
those 80 those 79 through 85 years man i
really want to expose that to people but
i'm not trying to expose me mugging
laughing at the gas station i really
want them to know the pain i was walking
around with and that's really tough to
express
when you're writing i want them to
understand that
uh i know that
from the minute i saw george perez
at school or the first time i saw you on
the bus at 8 40 or 7 whenever i caught
the bus that's when the pain disappeared
until that night at 12 when the coke
would start wearing off exactly and that
pain would come back i want people to
understand that so that's what's taking
so [ __ ] long and besides leak he's
busting my balls he's always doing
something he wants to go [ __ ] get it
together places are buffalo sauce that's
where i live
anyway yeah i'm an irvine wednesday
night like i said we got the shout outs
let me start with some paperwork here
lee i still have not gone to pick up my
[ __ ] suit you know why because i'm
lazy because it's somewhere where
i never opt but i gotta tell you
something
uh
if you're ever going to get a suit
there's a time of the year where you
want to have a suit at some places
even for myself all right i'm a bum
but
every man looks better in a suit
indochina is one of indochino is one of
the largest made to measure menswear
brands they are making it easy for men
to get great fitting they're making it
easy for you to get great fitting high
quality suits and shirts and an
incredible price here's how it works
okay you visit the
indochino.com or drop by one of the nine
north american showrooms
you pick from hundreds of fabrics and
patterns
you choose your customizations from
lapels to pleats to jacket linings and
more you submit your body measurements
you kick back relax and get ready to
step into the best most stylish suit
you've ever worn in just four weeks and
between me and you it comes even quicker
than that
this week my listeners can get any
premium listen to me any premium
indochino suit
for just 389 at
indochino.com when entering church when
you check out that's 50 off listen to me
it's christmas time you want to start
the year off looking good that's 50 off
regular price for made to measure
premium suit plus you ready for this the
shipping is free that's indochino.com
promo code church c-h-u-r-c-h
for any premium suit for just 389
and free shipping lee and i get three
suits for 100 bucks but you can't smoke
a cigarette by us or will burn to death
you know what i'm saying
this is a real suit this is real
material this is real fabric indochino
has amazing holiday deals right now on
their shirts pants and other products
too you'll never have to worry about bad
fitting suits or expensive trips to the
tailor again get ready to look like a
million bucks do me a favor uncle joey
wants you to look good and feel good if
you look good man you're gonna feel good
inside when you walk into a room you
have more confidence here it is
indochino.com
right now and get a super 389 when you
enter church at checkout that's my
christmas present [ __ ] all right
before the show tonight we were talking
about
driving experiences last week in boston
lee and i paid
371 dollars for a ride
that lee could have got us 160 dollars
on left
okay
now
i want to spread the word all right i've
used lyft maybe two times lee loves them
they legaliz
watches them you know lee uses them
more than anything what's the last of
you use them to the airport or something
didn't you
i use them all the time to the airport i
use them around town when i like even at
night even if i'm not even going out to
drink it so it's nice i i took them down
to amoeba that time it's just nice it's
a nice experience the drivers are very
kind to you it's it's a great it's great
so i'm going to tell you a smart way to
earn extra money and get a 500 bonus all
right you're going to drive for lift
right now you're probably unemployed you
don't know what to do
hey man you got bills i'm going to tell
you what you're in between jobs you're
looking to earn some money you're
looking to pay put away money for
college you know you want to go back to
school you know you want to write the
great american novel
listen this is 24 hours you can work
whatever shift you want on your time
your hours
drive for lyft you're tired of waiting
tables and you love to drive well here
it is drive for lift the ride sharing
app that lets you be your own boss pick
your own hours and earn up to 1500 bucks
a week driving your own
personal car okay
the other ride sharing apps out there
but everyone loves driving for lyft best
because they treat their drivers right
lots of people started as customers now
they drive for lyft it's a flexible way
to make extra money anytime anywhere
with your car
driving philip pays up to 35 an hour and
getting started is fast and easy you can
drive mornings nights or weekends just
flip into your driver mode put your
little hat on and bam stop making money
plus only lyft drivers can earn tips
from within the app and those add up
real fast and you don't have to wait
days or weeks to get paid because you
get cash instantly with express pay it
all adds up it's super flexible you keep
your own tips and you get paid when you
need extra cash do me a favor all right
the holidays are coming you don't want
to be broke it's a horrible feeling you
know what it's like to be broke in the
holidays is terrible sign up today go to
lyft.com
joey and right now lyft has a special
offer for my listeners you get a 500
new driver bonus when you sign up using
our show go to lyft.com
joey today you can start making money
and get your 500 new driver bonus that's
right go to lyft.com joey again lyft.com
joey i want to thank lyft i want to
thank my man honest for always having
our back when i'm flying you know me
alfred brain 100 money back guarantee i
want to thank indochino and i want to
thank cso for giving your [ __ ] joey
you're right and i want to thank my man
george perez i want to thank samantha
for driving him and i want to thank lee
for eating poison i gave you sucker
look at the shape of you you're [ __ ]
you're looking good though i'm proud of
you i'm [ __ ] i'm proud of your
girlfriend you're making it happen
you're going to get a house soon
she'll have her own driver you'll be the
butler
you're going to go home and get ready
and she'll be the chef you cook a blue
apron at night hey if i i'll retire i'll
retire at 30. i love you [ __ ]
we'll be back tuesday
before thanksgiving so you can take it
on the plane with your wednesday or when
you're driving you can listen to it with
your friends and [ __ ] one more time
george perez lee syed samantha and i'll
see you [ __ ] at the irvine
improv stay black and beautiful madonna
burn it up for your lovely that's what
you're gonna play put that [ __ ]
unless you got something else put on
whatever you want lee go ahead do what
you got there
oh [ __ ] a little double j [ __ ]
[Music]
and
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
the things